hey everyone
dan do you know our theme song
dan levy my best friend of 18 years do
you know that
you say it so aggressively
do you know the theme song i know it's
like
it's like yeah i do it's like it's like
very like uh
80s it was like very like 80s like uh
sitcom yeah mr belvedere yeah yeah
which is what we based whitney on yes
florida real quick before i get to this
interview with my best friend of all
time dan levy who's going to spill all
of my deepest darkest secrets and ruin
my career and credibility i just want to
let y'all know i am still coming to
florida despite the fact that nobody
wants to get back today no way you're
going to florida just tell them now
there's no no one's going to florida
ever again
it's never happening
cancel florida cancel shows
i'll be there uh i will be there uh
i'm not lying i mean i do lie about a
lot of things which dan is about to
reveal to everyone on this podcast but
one thing i'm not lying about is that i
will be uh doing two shows on september
10th at the ponte vedra concert hall i
do
in halls now uh two shows september 11th
at the capitol theater in clearwater so
come celebrate september 11th with the
scientologists and me in clearwater
november 12th i'll be at the coral
springs cemetery hold on hold on so
you're gonna be you're gonna be
in the covent capital the country on
september 11th and you're telling people
to come to this
okay continue
come
come stand with someone else in the
lobby and then fall over because of
covet in honor of september 11th coral
springs center for the arts because what
i am doing is art right now on stage
this will be an artistic performance uh
i'll be at the hard rock live in orlando
november 13th
october 14th at the riverside casino in
riverside i'm going to be gambling
literally and figuratively with my
health
uh and then october 15th i'll be at the
hoyt sherman place that somehow is not a
typo in
des moines october 22nd i'm gonna go to
anaheim california to play the city
national grove i do comedy in groves now
well this is the only show you're
actually gonna do
because you're gonna be able to drive
there
and you will be there yes so you're
definitely gonna be in anaheim so
everyone in florida get your tickets and
fly to anaheim and watch whitney perform
at the grove
right next to the american girl doll
store i might just go to
i might just go to disneyland the same
day as i do my show i'll take my inner
child on a little spin on the teacups
maybe have people rear end my inner
child on the bumper cars i think that
was your first joke
that was my opener
you first met me no my opener when you
first met me was
i know
my last name is cummings i know you guys
think that that's crazy but just so you
know it is a stage name
my real last name is cumshot
a plus break
november 4th i'm gonna be at the pabst
theater in milwaukee
see you there buy tickets then i'll be
back in the heartland in december with
two ohio dates on december 9th i'm in
columbus playing the joann davidson
theater no relation to joanne of joanne
fabric that i know of december 10th i'll
be at the agora theater in cleveland if
you're agoraphobic come anyway the
hockey team i googled this and i just
got in a fight with grace about it i saw
that the hockey team
in cleveland was called the monsters and
i was like oh my god that's so cool and
then i looked it up and
they don't have an nhl team i guess that
was the name of their children's
league the little mo
the ahl team but what's the difference
whatever now i'm on megan's law so
there's that there's that nashville i'll
be at the polk theater on january 28
2022 bring your bachelorette party isn't
that the bachelorette party capital of
the world
benton bachelorette capital of the world
and hot chicken last time i was there i
made a joke about pink mace and someone
threw mace at me from the audience it's
also where a bunch of people from l.a
moved and were like wait why am i living
here now
oh la opened up again and i can't sing
whoops
vegas i'm still coming in the mirage on
august 7th
they did just reinstate the mask policy
which is frustrating but i say let's do
the show anyway and let's let's have fun
with it come on you have to wear a mask
inside in vegas let's just go full eyes
wide shut
i expect to look out at the audience at
the mirage show in vegas and on august
7th and just see jason voorhees masks
pennywise masks make it let's make it
fun let's make it weird an army hammer
mask
we know him who by the way dan and i
were in acting class with what was that
18 years ago that might have been that
long ago yes dan and i have been best
friends for how long well i met you when
i i think i met you on friendster
unfriendster in 2003.
wow yeah we were at an audition
for
we're at an audition
uh a tv show called oh oh oh easy it was
not a tv show well this was a pilot that
had not even been
commissioned by a network well somehow
we still had to audition for it jesus
even more embarrassing it was just like
someone's hobby yeah it was it was in
someone's apartment it was in someone's
apartment
this was back in the day when producers
could just have auditions in their
apartment and uh and yeah we we we there
we auditioned for like some weird stuff
pilot called hell date hell date then
did get picked up to be e.t later yeah
it got picked to be a tv show and they
did not
we auditioned in blackface but they
didn't like it for some reason we
auditioned for this for the sizzle which
was a mini pilot and we got it we shot
it we shot it and we were so funny in it
they picked it up and didn't use us and
you know what it was the premise of the
show looking back it was called hell
date and it was where
the idea was we were pranking people it
was like an undercover prank show
where we were like the worst dates
possible yeah that was the idea i think
i threw up on someone i had to do
absolutely no acting at all i just had
to be myself the entire time
we had to be like nightmare dates yeah
that was the idea and it it if they shot
every scene of the grove and that weird
italian restaurant and they would just
like shuttle us in they're like now you
prank the people and the people
were like we've been doing this all day
literally every time we would go on a
date with a new random person we would
just have to like fake puke on them and
like
or like spit blood out of our mouths
with like a weird blood cap like none of
it worked it was always so awkward it
was really weird but that's where we met
on on the set of hell day and it was
funny as we met there and i was like oh
you're so funny and then uh we're like
we got castness this is great and then
we weren't even in the show together
because we were on two different dates
so they're like whitney's in the beat i
was like wait that was great we had that
great audition together and i was like
where's whitney they're like oh no
you're not in you're on a different date
you're with this random person i just
remember us auditioning at like a dining
room table from ikea yes that's what it
is like he's not trying to assault me i
should be friends with him
and it worked which is the first thing i
just want to bring up about our
friendship because there is something
kind of amazing about the fact that like
there was never any sexual anything
between us ever yeah it was platonic
from the beginning from the jump from
the beginning of it all well like how
like like that is so wild
well you were dating
a guy with your roommate my roommate
stop saying it was the guy you knew i
mean it was your roommate yeah so i mean
as a normal person you meet someone
you're like oh this is my girlfriend
whitney i was like cool this is this is
you were just the first person in
hollywood who didn't try to recruit me
into scientology i was like will you be
my friend come on i mean it was like we
were 22
20 something no i think 24. really it
was like it was definitely early 20s
right and we were in that whole
weird early la thing where it's like
we're auditioning at dining room tables
we're taking acting classes and we were
in acting class together with the one
joe meganello
a one army hammer didn't try to nibble
me once very insulted
who else amy landecker
who was a member on transparent she was
in the coen brothers movie she's married
to um bradley whitford i saw her the
other night where like the people that
came out of that acting class it's just
so weird to think about richie keane who
now directs all that it's always sunny
in philadelphia movies and now is like
doing big studio movies yeah no it was
and it was such a weird thing because i
remember we it was like a weird therapy
that class it was and i really didn't
really i didn't i didn't like love it i
remember there was a thing worthy of
i i i appreciated what it could be this
class can be very
confu for the first like two hours in la
acting classes you're kind of just like
talking about your problems oh i
remember there was one this one acting
class we were sitting in a circle and i
was like i
think i'm gonna get into this we'll see
i was like i just want to like audition
for three kings or whatever
oh
three kings was a pilot there's a couple
like pilots
in tv shows like in the history of
actors in la that have this um
what's the word like um it's it's not
like a mythical like they're like
legendary in terms of like how big of a
deal they were to us at the time exactly
and looking back you're like that was so
meaningless
like things like i mean big bang theory
was one of them because i remember being
with like ricky lindholm all my
girlfriends that were like beautiful and
blonde like went out for that part but
it was like kaylee probably had it right
this is before we had been behind the
camera and created shows and he actually
thought we had a shot at getting tv
shows yeah but i remember
because i did audition big bang theory
too i remember getting those sides and i
was like okay 16 pages i'm never going
to get this i'm not i'm good i'm good
with like two pages one line but we were
auditioning at the time this is
important because
we went from auditioning to try to be
actors on shows to creating our own
shows yes because we couldn't we were
like the two people in the acting class
who were always trying to make the
scripts funnier because like this sucks
like we should add we were the comedians
and i was like i add jokes they're like
this is from spin city
this is hilarious and i was like okay
we're like this is awful so we were the
two people in the acting class who kept
trying to rewrite it and improvise and
they were like no you need to that's a
period a period's a period a calm is a
comma you need to do this and this and
we're like i don't we think we can make
this better yeah and we ended up
becoming creators and show runners
because we were the comics but there
were a couple things when you look back
and just like for anyone who thinks
something's a big deal that relationship
that job that whatever where it was like
three kings that was a pilot where
we were like working on it every day
trying to get it right trying to uh in
like what happened did it even i don't
even know i remember we were now we're
working
on you porn
three kings check it out check it out we
were working on it so much in like the
audi class then we worked on it like in
at your apartment and then i remember
calling you
calling it like one of the more be like
i gotta go the phones look like that i
gotta go over there they weren't even
here yet it was 1991. i was like whitney
you did rock the t-mobile sidekick on
your van dutch jeans and your belt
buckle it's true i knew damn when he had
a chain wallet from delias
not from delias from urban outfitters
no but i remember calling you and we
like uh we i am we were like i am god
we are aiming like our audition lines
back i don't know what we're doing but
they remind me oh no dan if you have
things i don't have do you have things i
have
i have baby carrots
and barbecue sauce because it's very
important even though we are now
currently in whitney's podcast studio
which is in her you know very very large
home hidden behind 25 gates that's also
being renovated behind more gates there
was a time when i met her
when she had zero money and all she
could eat was carrots and barbecue sauce
oh my gosh and she would dip them as we
would write jokes and it was the worst
thing to ever see and one time i just
stopped her and i grabbed the carrots
and i was like what are you eating and
she was like oh this is like you know
it's like grab and go and i was like no
no grab and go this is over and i
grabbed them from you and i was like
let's order in and out or something
but anyway so this is for you for later
oh i couldn't order from in and out
because that's where my boyfriend's
worked that's the thing i didn't want
them to run into each other that is very
true i cannot believe you brought these
by the way this looks delicious as i
look at it it does not sweet baby raise
i couldn't afford this barbecue sauce
for you for this like the john's like
random um sale
uh uh what is it the sale rack uh
barbecue sauce mine didn't have honey
and what was i a millionaire was i marie
antoinette
i liter i was gonna bring this up later
i thought you forgot about that no you
always we would be i can't believe you
remember this yeah whitney lived behind
the comedy store we would go there and
we would like write jokes like super
late and and you would just be eating
that all you'd eat was that i know i i
was basically eating barbecue sauce
the baby carrots were just the vehicle
to get the barbecue i would just eat
condiments were you do you remember when
i would eat the beef jerky with maple
syrup
oh did i
no but it doesn't remind me that since
tooth out with 2003 since i met since i
met whitney no matter what has happened
you know all your success your entire
life i would say
once a week
i get a text
from all sorts of people like just the
most random from like people who are
just i don't even know comedians agents
people who like own buildings
baseball players i'll just get this text
out of nowhere is whitney okay
all the time
and i always write back the same thing
no
no stop texting me this of course not
he's not okay thanks oh my god
all the time there was i mean because
people do not belie like when i talk
about the first of all no one believes i
even am the age that i am you're one of
the few people that can testify i know
i've seen the driver's license yeah yeah
and then there the time when i was i
remember when i would just eat those
those ice blendeds from
coffee bean i would i would just have
those it was like milkshakes all day
remember i was like balding when you met
me i looked like theo vaughn i had a rat
tail in the back but it wasn't a choice
it was just for malnutrition but then as
you got more successful you ate worse
when we were i don't want to jump around
but when we were doing the sitcom all
you ate was powdered peanut butter okay
that was a quality item
that i found on a german website that
was a dot net
peanutbutter.net i well here i mean
there's so much to cover in this area
but
you were definitely around the time when
i was a very unhealthy person
right now
unlike now where i only drink skinny
girl margaritas out of little birthday
horse cups
when it's not my birthday
um but yeah because that because i mean
you were there when i was really in
it's weird because you were like my
healthy friend
and it's so weird that you wanted to be
friends with me at all i kind of forced
you to be friends with me no i first of
all for me obviously like being being a
funny person is the most important thing
for me being a funny person being a good
person right so i feel like i wasn't a
good person but you are that's a lie
like that's what i feel like is that's
what you're putting out especially like
back then when you were like you know
the goal was to be like my last name is
gumshot or whatever your first joke was
like i don't care
um but but i but like you're hilarious
and you are you are you you know you're
a good person you just don't like to
like actually like you know flaunt let
anyone know god forbid people like me
and i have positive youtube comments
but you and i i feel like we clicked
instantly because number one you were
like the first person i met in hollywood
where i felt no like
creepiness i felt no
i have to sleep with this part not that
any you know anyone
anyone in comedy had done that at the
time i think for me like all the guys in
comedy felt the need to like haze me or
they were flirting with me and i just
didn't understand what was going on
because i was so ambitious and i was so
focused on making it and you were the
first person i met that was super super
funny but not
super messed up
and i don't think i i still don't think
i've met someone that is as funny as you
but also just like genuinely kind
because most comedy comes from like
severe darkness and you were always so
funny but not just you know
a bummer because i felt like with a lot
of comedians i had to like
like
be sicker than i was just so they
thought i was cool and you were just
like let's go to the mall and like let's
go to claire's and get our nose pierced
whereas everyone else was like let's do
blow and i'm like fine you know like you
were like the hell like i don't know
what i would have done like what would
have happened to me if i didn't find you
i don't know it would have been so many
people will be dead so many
dozens
i saved one life and i i saved so many
more but it was also like and then you
instantly became my friend but i hadn't
done comedy when we met you were you had
done stand up for years before yeah you
came back i know exactly what happened
you came back from the sundance film
festival where you were hosting an event
i was hosting the sundance festival
dailies for the sundance channel i had
made these little reels of myself so i
would go to like the flea market
on melrose in hollywood and have someone
come shoot me and i'd be like here i am
at the melrose flea market and i'm going
to show you i was like just make i was
trying to be like brooke burke or
something i was just making
reels like sizzle reels to show people
that i could be funny on camera i would
like interview people on the street make
these demo reels
and jay moore was hosting the sundance
festival dailies i got the the
the video to someone it got to sundance
festival dailies j moore said i was
funny and i became a correspondent on
that and then then i hit that out of the
park uh
because i was such an idiot like i was i
i didn't um
know enough about the business to have
any respect for anybody so when i was a
correspondent interviewing people the
sundance film festival i was so
irreverent and rude that it ended up
being funny and then i got a manager out
of it yes and your manager was like you
should do stand-up the manager signed me
solely off of my interaction with jay
moore right solely off of the fact that
jay moore started sort of clowning on me
and roasting me and because of my
childhood that is where i shine and so i
started roasting him back just i wasn't
trying to be funny i was trying to hurt
him because i felt attacked and he was
like i've never seen a woman be able to
go toe-to-toe with him like that and
then sign me off of that i had never
done stand-up before yeah and then you
and then you came out and then you just
got into it and then so so you were you
i knew you for like only a few months
and then you're like i'm just i'm gonna
do it and then you start doing it yeah
and then we're like then we got together
we started writing jokes together and
then we decided to do a show together
yes we did we decided to do a show at a
place called the mbar embar was the
spot yes to be at in
uh the it was more the alt comedy scene
i mean we kind of because in in new york
you kind of start in clubs and in la
there aren't as many clubs and it's
really hard to get past at places like
the improv the comedy store even hermosa
comedy of magic club um but we were
doing bowling alleys bars sushi
restaurants and there was this place
called embar that we started a show
together it was called comedy on your
face i'm pretty sure you thought of the
title
which still is like kind of genius to me
this is our first flyer it was paul
scheer
mindy kaling yep she did an abraham
lincoln joke i remember that it was very
funny i remember what it was but i
remember with abraham lincoln she used
to have a really funny joke where she
and i don't remember what it was but it
was just about how when she would go
into like a boutique store people will
go like hey mama mama like there was a
moment where everyone every girl called
other girls mama i do remember that time
i remember that joke it was i don't
remember what the punchline was ben
glebe that's written on your richie
keane richie keane now a huge director
and directs a lot of it's always sunny
in philadelphia
episodes had a joke that was so funny
about
um and i talked about this when topher
grace was on uh because they're good
friends about how
zucchini muffins
you know zucchini muffins
yeah how every morning some guy has to
cut the zucchini
knowing that no one's gonna buy this
fucking muffin
it's such a stew it's like so dumb but
it's so funny to me to think about the
person cutting those zucchinis just
incredible yeah now justin willman now
justin willman who is your friend my
good friend from college justin's like
famous now oh yeah justin has a show uh
magic for humans on netflix yeah he's
just crushing it but he was how did he
get famous famous because it's weird
when you know somebody and you you know
them as and then they get you've known
him since
justin is just a guy who just i met him
day one of no i met him when i was a
senior in high school visiting college
he was on the street corner with the
visor handing out flyers to come to a
magic show in a basement i swear to god
and that guy didn't stop his work out
how ronan pharaoh has it investigated
that
no no it was a college basement yeah
yeah
and uh and yeah he's just you know super
talented you know just and and he just
just kept on going and just kept on
building and building a building and
then he had this magic show on netflix
then it really but but also but he was i
remember you told a story about how you
used to go out with him in college and
it was hard to pick up girls
no it was easy because he had like a
thousand foam bunnies in his brown
leather jacket everywhere we went he'd
be like bunny and girls are like oh my
god i love you you're so cute
he's the only magician who girls ever
say god he's so cute that's the only
time because he was full of bunnies oh
so many i have i always whenever they
get jealous i think of like being in
boston calm in the freezing cold and he
had a weird like 70s brown little jacket
and would be under a gazebo and like
snow would be flowing it'd be like this
beautiful night and he's pulling bunnies
out of everywhere just seeing how trying
to impress girls in a park insane full
watership down like this is traumatizing
and then uh but i remember one time you
said something funny about how you were
like trying to flirt with a girl and you
like couldn't get her attention and then
you turned around and he was like
holding fire
yeah always you're like shit god damn it
he had the he had the fire wallet he
would always take it out he was like hey
manny
comes out
has he ever told you any magician
secrets why we lived together when i we
lived together and i saw him practice a
lot of tricks but you know magic is
tricky it's hard it's very hard to
figure out i saw you know we live
together we'd be like doves everywhere
and fake thumbs all over the floor so i
would like figure out some thumb tricks
but the actual like especially now he's
doing like illusions it's impossible to
figure out
there were fake thumbs up oh there's a
thousand thousand prosthetic fingers
well there's an episode of whitney
i remember my dad came to visit us and
he gave it to our apartment that we were
both sharing and he looked around he's
like what the fuck is this place
because there was we like had so much
diesel jeans everywhere it was like
diesel clothes fake thumbs was the magic
trick how to get women to disappear yeah
exactly
they saw our outfits but uh yeah and
then there was one day where
um he was he was doing college shows so
i had to i i took him i took him to the
airport and then he called me he's like
hey buddy there's some issues it was
right after 9 11. and he's like there's
some issues at the airport they won't
let me travel with my bunny so he sent
his bunny on a super shuttle back to our
apartment and i had to wait and we have
a live one a live bunny oh jesus and and
the guy with knocking dory's like i got
a money and i was like yeah i guess i'll
take it he's like why why'd i pick up a
bunny at the airport i was like it's a
long story he's a magician just drive
away and don't think about this ever
again sir by the way saying it's full of
heroin would make more sense it's full
of hair oh got it no problem that makes
more sense it's for a magician like
no thanks it's full of thumbs
so i have a bunch of pictures that i
want us to go through and i want you to
tell the story about what it was oh this
is a picture of me in a banana suit that
was from whitney i'm wearing little
yellow panties with white hose and i'm
wearing a child's banana costume this
only dan levy could explain what in the
sam hell is going on well wasn't this am
i being trafficked this was am i being
trafficked by the chiquita banana this
was the scene from taken that was cut
out
the worst scene
this is the first scene took her no one
took her untaken
taken
not taken starring whitney cummings hard
pass
um this i believe this was from whitney
season one was this during like we were
shooting promos yeah during pro doing
promos because i don't know if they
still do it but remember how nbc would
like have people float up you know in
the bottom of the screen and it would be
like whitney in a banana costume i don't
think i have any pictures of me because
because basically what happens when you
do a tv show that got this kind of
promotion we had no idea we were gonna
get this kind of promotion we had no
idea anyone would care like when we made
this we were like comedians that were
just like messing around we never in a
million years thought this would happen
right and so when you get picked up
they're like come we're gonna shoot a
bunch of promos you're in front of a
green screen you have no idea what's
going on i was just and they're separate
people so all the people you're working
with to make your tv show are not
involved in making the commercials or
the market that's right so you think you
know if you're getting along with your
executives but sometimes you you totally
are they're cool and they're like get it
they're in with you they're in it from
the beginning yeah then the market team
takes over and you're like hey guys how
come i'm in a banana costume they're
like not our thing you're like no but
you're you're my friends
yeah it's is this not a show about fruit
oh is this not you're not a runt in the
show no
like it but also there was like so much
promotion they put us in front in front
of a green screen and i have no idea
what's going on i'm like can i bring my
friend dan they're like no i was like
well he's coming anyway this is like my
posse
and i'm in front of a green screen and
they just put they just throw there's a
table of props yes there's a giant
plastic table of like goggles and
big funny sunglasses and sunglasses with
a little like you know mustache and then
like a beach ball and you're just you
have like 19 men in suits and this was
the beginning of everyone thinking that
i was in charge of the entire whitney
show from from day one because no one
else wanted to go to like the promo
shoot and when he's like damn we'll come
like i'll go to the promo shoot sunday 6
a.m why not and then all of a sudden
everyone's there and i'm like yeah she
should not wear that but this thing here
was like i guess he's in charge
that i trusted he was in just like neon
pink air maxes and a tank top and i'm
like this is my larry davis
everyone's like jesus christ
remember when everyone called me vagina
films
yes
i do remember that my trusty sidekick
had to leave at 5 15 to do a four-minute
spot at the haha cafe i know i didn't
leave one day to host a red bull event i
felt bad about that
i was like you guys we're gonna have to
we're gonna have to shoot this fast dan
has to go audition for a tbs pilot you
know you did text me one time the one
time i did feel bad you didn't text me
you're like hey did you quit and i was
like i got this red bull thing i'll be
back soon i'm like i'm so sorry that my
main writer can't be here he's going to
do new faces in montreal and there's
like a nightmare but i'm like here i'm
just gonna hire my best friend to
basically be in charge and then um
and then they have you like just they're
like just dance and they'll put music on
and you're like yeah i have a tv show
sure i have no idea what i'm doing cut
two the super bowl is on
and then people are like why are you
dancing on the bottom of the screen of
the super bowl like i don't know and and
everyone hates me because i'm like
dancing in front of tom brady and
everyone's like get that cunt off the
screen people are like wait is whitney
in the banana costume like yeah i
produced that
it was like a nightmare i had no idea
what i was doing and this was at a time
where promotion was just like remember
it was like um someone was like i just
went to a movie theater and you were on
the bag of popcorn
i'm so sorry well there was a period in
the 90s when like the marketing company
the marketing divisions of the networks
basically controlled everything yeah
they were just so in charge and they
just made hits so i feel like people
still trust them especially these big
networks so when it was whitney was like
the first time in a long time that there
was a comedian with their own show with
her own name yeah it was a big deal i
don't think people even realized that
whitney on nbc was the first show that
was picked up of like pilots that year
it had you you were able to like you
know hire some amazing all amazing
writers and you'd like you had you had
this great staff andy ackerman you had
like the whole thing going it was also
it it and i feel weird saying this
because it feels like i'm like a
narcissist or something but it also
tested really highly yeah so they don't
just give you a bunch of money because
they like you or because you like
flirted with an executive or because you
were like networking you know it tested
really highly in like in vegas or
wherever like strangers liked it so they
gave us all this marketing money yeah
and like another thing is what people
don't realize or i like to say to myself
is that it doesn't matter like what you
think the show is if you like it if you
hate it making a tv show is impossible
it's very very hard and it takes as much
work to make a show that people don't
like as it is to make sure people do
like wow so we were like you know
working until two in the morning three
in the morning like killing ourselves
something that that a lot of people do a
lot of the shows that people like like
now i mean the flea bags which are
brilliant the romneys which are
brilliant they're making six episodes
they're making 10 episodes we were
making 24 episodes a year we were doing
an episode a week yeah whitney coined it
pencils down comedy because she'd get so
stressed out because i think to explain
it's like a multi-cam schedule right
it's it's really difficult it's an old
school schedule it's fun it's a train
that is running and you cannot stop it
and you shoot it when you're not done
making it so i remember i was like i get
to make a tv show this is so cool i have
all these great ideas because i got to
work on the pilot for a year and the
pilot was great it got picked up it got
you know all this um i tested really
highly the networks but then you're like
oh you have to make a bunch of shows
that are as good as the you have to make
23 more shows that are as good as the
pilot that you worked on for a year but
you only have a week to make it and you
have even less time because that's right
the way it works is you do a table or
even read the script they laugh then we
get notes right and it was a new show so
a new show always gets like tons of
notes then you get all these so they
spent a ton of money on right there's a
lot of writing on it so then they come
back to the writers room you're there
right and we start rewriting the episode
based on notes then you have to go do
some sort of interview or go on melrose
and interview like fucking someone at
pizza hut or whatever you're doing to
promote the show go cheat exactly yeah
you have to make up some lie to us and
to your boyfriend because you're
cheating on him with someone else who we
know and we had no idea uh by the way my
favorite we will get back to the making
of multicam in a second because rob
mcelhaney was on mcelhenny
was on did i say that right nailed it
nailed it was on last i've just i'm i'm
too skinny girl margaritas in and uh we
were talking we got really granular
about the making of television people
like loved it so now i'm like super
excited to talk about this but my
favorite story about damn
and proof that he is my best friend like
ride or die forever is one time i was
dating this guy that because i in my 20s
i was always dating sketchy guys that i
was in your 20s
so i'm in my office in the whitney
writers room i'm in my office you come
in it's like 10 o'clock at night and i
was like
obviously ashamed of my behavior because
i think i was in a relationship with
someone i was emotionally cheating with
someone else so i did technically cheat
on someone i was with and then i was
dating someone who doesn't have the best
reputation he's not beloved i was
ashamed that i was with him i don't
think everyone approved of him i think
your approval over the guys i date
you're always
the person who's approval i want the
most so i think i i hide them from you
the most because i know you're going to
be real you're not going to be fake with
me but this is why i have 10 like all of
your ex boyfriend's phone numbers are in
my phone because i have some time with
them at some point of your relationship
i find myself with them doing just like
a one-on-one bro day and i'm just like
hey yeah you're great you're cool and
you're like they're cool i'm like yeah
he was really cool i think it's gonna
really look like he cheated on him
you're like fuck
and then i have to have to break up with
the boyfriends you cheated on
you don't even break up you cheat on
them and leave them and i'm like hey man
good seeing you sorry things didn't work
out
want to go for a hike tomorrow shit
should we cancel that trip to thailand
so so i think introduce because i don't
really have parents to introduce people
i date to so what i in like you're like
my oh my god you're about to meet dan
that's like meeting my mom or meeting my
dad you know so i was i think being very
shady and i i you always know when i'm
lying because you know me so well and i
was like it was 10 o'clock and i was
like i'm just gonna head and go do um
like a quick yoga class
and you just looked at me and you just
went
why are you lying
i was like why are you lying to me right
now
i'm just over here trying to write like
episode 108 like um i don't care i'm
trying to keep your career alive it was
just like it was there's no friendship
like a friendship where someone's going
why are you lying what is wrong with you
like me of all people
oh my god it was so funny that was a
that was a crazy time because i remember
remember when a boyfriend i was dating
sent me a gun at work
[Laughter]
yeah it got pretty crazy it got pretty
and by the way so we're this is going on
while you're trying to make a show yeah
and two shows make two shows i wish i
had this voicemail i have a voicemail
from whitney from i think it was it had
to be my 30th birthday i had a birthday
party downtown i don't know why it's the
last time everyone downtown but but it
was my birthday party downtown you
needed less friends who were like i just
i have too many friends i'm gonna have a
party downtown and in the morning you're
like i'll see you there and then you
left me a voicemail and you're like uh
hey i um i'm trying to finish this two
bro girl script and i have to finish
this whitney script and you know what i
honestly like i'll just hang out with
you like when i'm rich
and that was the first not lie she ever
said that was her only not lie here we
are here we are it happened it happened
we're hanging out eight years later
it is fascinating though because like
from your point of view
so we
you know we're really good friends real
friends comics
i bring you on to work on whitney
because my i just want to have fun with
my friends like i don't realize when
you're you know at the time when
comedians got shows it's not like now
like romney or or phoebe waller bridge
or
you know um like donald glover where
people give the talent the benefit of
the doubt at the time when we made that
show it was very much a comedian as a
child who is to be babysat who doesn't
know what they're doing
me being a girl probably didn't help at
the time but just the idea of like oh
this comedian is going to have a show
and they need to and they don't know
what they're doing well also you were
put into this multicam machine you know
which also was kind of like a whole
thing to actually learn like you can't
just like show up and be like all right
let's make a tv show because it's like
no you gotta get on this train and you
have to hit like x y and z each week you
can't just like kind of hang out and
like feel the show it's like it airs on
friday yeah yeah yeah this airs and you
have to do nine talk shows in new york
tomorrow morning and the show has to be
shot yeah and the network executive's
telling me i look tired i'm like yeah no
shit well i remember you know we were we
were trying to like you know rewrite the
episode and you were you know obviously
you're starving you're exactly producer
you're writing it so you would be like
trying to figure out breaking episode
but also getting network notes and some
network notes would be like whitney
looks too tired and you would i remember
you were reading the notes and we're
like trying to figure out like i don't
know some like dating episode or
something and you're just like i'm like
yeah and then like the a story blah blah
and you're just like
i need a green tea latte and you just
like walked away she can cry on camera i
know wait wait this is all the time film
this film get that we need that for the
finale so then you left and you like
went to go get fucking you went you're
like i'm gonna go to editing and you're
like upset you're really upset i'm
taking my barbecue sauce with my carrots
and i'm going to post production and
then like an hour later you came back
from editing you're like they're cgi in
my eyes
and you found out that like in the same
day that you look tired and they were
also using cgi to take the bags under
your eyes because uh you were look so
tired so then you were like i'm a
cartoon i'm a cartoon like having the
worst nervous breakdown in front of
everyone screaming at your cartoons i'm
tired
it was totally crazy i i remember
because so i i remember being i remember
they were kind of trying to protect me
from the notes about my appearance a
little bit because there was there was
um there were all these meetings and it
was like okay meeting for the ep meeting
for the eps and i'm supposed to be in
that meeting and then i remember one day
they were like oh why don't you just go
to wardrobe or like why don't you go do
like rehearsal don't you go home early
there was a lot of like why don't you go
home once you get some rest i'm like
there's so much work to do i have to
stay you know and i never i always want
to pull my weight and i'm like a writer
first you know i'm a comic i want to be
in there you know and i remember
everyone's trying to send me home and
then one day
they sent me home and i was like okay
like someone lied to me and was like
we're done for the day like it's a
hiatus or something so i go home and but
i'd like forgotten something you know
my gun or some my rifle that was sent to
me
so i go back in and there's a meeting
happening that i don't know about i'm
like why are all the eps in a meeting
that i wasn't in
and then later i
saw some and then i i was like
something's going on and then my
assistant at the time megan hearn
i was like uh she was on some things i
was like what was that meeting and she
was like oh and she kind of felt torn
like i think i have to tell you about
this but i also shouldn't and whatever
and she was like uh there's
an email chain that i'm on that you're
not on and
i think it's about that and i looked at
it and it was notes about episode i
remember because it was episode 103
it was notes about can we make whitney
less shrill
and it was about an episode where the
whole episode was where chris's
character shushed me and i gave him the
silent treatment the whole episode so i
didn't speak the whole time
and i was like you guys think i'm shrill
when i don't speak and now shrill is a
hit show
time has changed we were so far ahead of
this their complaint about an episode
where i did not speak was that i was
shrill and i was like i don't think i'm
going to be able to win this
i know it was it was just it was but it
was insane no that was i remember at the
i went to a because i i always wanted to
know everybody's name everybody the crew
everyone and i i prided myself on
knowing everyone's name and then we went
to a wrap party and there was someone i
didn't know and i went up to him and
said oh my god i'm so my name's whitney
you know
who are you i don't think i know you and
he goes oh yeah i'm the person that
fixes your eye bags in post
and i was like what and he was like yeah
yeah and he was like i fix your face and
post because when we would watch the
show at like viewing parties i did look
like a piece of cake
i was like there's
there's no way that's what i look like
because i look like steve buscemi
nor and then i looked at myself on
camera i was like wow the lighting's
amazing patty lee our dp
and i did notice though that that after
episode one two three when there would
be a uh shot on me all of a sudden like
more and more people would show up with
these big white bounces like under me
there would be like five spotlights
flashlights people surrounding me
with like all kinds of lights like
you know and so um
yeah i i looked tired was like the main
note and then there was an episode where
i had to cry because i was getting
proposed when i did but then they
animated it out so you couldn't tell i
was crying and then look when he's a bad
actress it's like no i'm not a bad
actress i just have bad genetics and i
have bags under my eyes and they wanted
me to not have bags instead of actually
play the authenticity of the moment i'm
not a bad actress i'm animated i'm not a
bad actress i'm just snoopy i'm jessica
rabbit
we now take what is most likely a
startling break from our interview with
dan levy to talk about one of my
favorite brands daily harvest i recently
dazzled my lover with the culinary
skills
that i have thanks to daily harvest and
luckily we caught it on camera
hit it what does this mean grace hungies
i need nom noms
i think you can make your own lunch
you're a big girl oh my god
you just call me fat
i'm gonna make my own lunch because
grace has decided to you're not gonna
play those like a set of bongo drums i
was going to and i thought he would make
fun of me but
i can't win uh and this was in the
freezer wow i couldn't decide whether i
wanted the brussels sprouts green lentil
butternut squash tahini
hazelnut tumeric
or the cauliflower spinach basil olive
oil cashew nutritional yeast so i got
both these are so easy grace i don't
even need you to help me okay
you're fired
so all i have to do is fill these up
with a little wawa
right hold on
[Music]
oh we're out of water
huh
so ridiculously this one looks so
delicious those look good okay
i have a girlfriend until you get me a
microwave then i'm a wife
how many minutes i think it's like four
four minutes ridiculously easy done
one button look at that this gives me
plenty of time to micromanage while i'm
waiting
you
is it tonight
i love my job so
much dear diary i would do this for free
okay so now i'm just gonna mix it up
halfway through
[Music]
wow la dee oh my god that smells so good
do you guys know daily harvest never
uses preservatives added sugar
artificial anything you don't say huh
they've asked us to include at least one
coffee point in these ads
they
are all about leaving the earth in a
better place than they found it
not just for us but for future
generations to come because we're all
three of us are for sure having
cook kids wife material come get your
delicious home-cooked meal with all
natural ingredients with no chemicals or
preservatives or any of the garbage that
you normally need but wait don't block
this out there's too much water in here
at me
i just made a home-cooked meal
out of uh
wonderful vegetables and uh broccolini
and um
[Music]
roasted red peppers that i roasted
myself and grew in my garden
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm on some white shit up here
yeah
i'm holding it
even the most discerning of men that are
smart because they wear glasses won't
even know that you didn't cook it
yourself
trick your man the daily harvest
and then say you're pregnant he has to
call you back
we love daily harvest we eat it for
realsies we're obsessed with it stay
cool common collected during the summer
heat go to dailyharvest.com and enter
code good for you to get 25 off your
first box that's code good for you for
25 off your first box at
dailyharvest.com
dailyharvest.com we are not going to
transition into talking about a sponsor
that has solved a problem i've been
struggling with for at least at least 10
years
i've spent so much of my life struggling
to eat healthy to use healthy products
be it shampoos lotions deodorants we
grew up just
poisoning ourselves constantly i can
pronounce any of the ingredients in any
of the products that i ate or put on my
body when i was a child people think i
have good skin i think i'm just embalmed
i have to combat all of the damage that
i've done to myself emily was with me uh
at the beginning of this journey
remember when i first started trying to
be healthy back when you're my assistant
oh seven years ago i remember
i remember i got someone to come in my
home to try to because you don't know
what's in your products i would buy
products i thought they were natural i
thought they were organic but no no we
had a woman remember we hired a woman
that came in and told us everything was
killing us the paint on the walls the
wood on the floors the dishwasher she
got rid of them she came in she got rid
of the microwave she was sending us in
the direction of natural products which
were very hard to find at the time so
here's what we did remember we had to we
had to clean out the fridge we cleaned
out the fridge we had to go to four
different grocery stores we had to get
your milk
from a woman who slept with her goats in
northern california and i no i was never
specified whether she slept with them or
laid on them and i had to meet her
extracurricularly at grocery stores
around the greater los angeles area and
she would lecture you about which olive
oils had which chemicals in them and
some olive oils have been heated up so
they have carcinogens in them
everything's a carcinogen and even
natural um deodorants had and decaf
coffee had formaldehyde in it it was
like even when you're trying to be
healthy you can mess up well she seems
fun and not scary at all your home is a
death trap remember
we had to do the grounding
i was getting to that oh
so i'll call her
sarah
wanted whitney and i to go out into
whitney and me to go out into the earth
and plant our feet in the ground to
ground ourselves it's how you get um uh
energy from the earth to like stabilize
your electrodes or something small
hiccup
the ground we stood on could not have
any emf or power line or any type of
electrical
uh contamination
so
i
had to
call the city of los angeles
and get
physical maps
this isn't true yes it is this is true
no idea i have no idea this is all sarah
i had no idea like uh uh what like a
grid why couldn't she tell you why can't
the wicked bridge of the west tell you
where they were she didn't know
emily called the city to get where the
power lines were and where all the phone
lines were buried underground safe place
to stand for those two explorers lewis
and clark i'm standing with these maps
being like okay well if we stand a
quarter past a sundial mile of the grass
only two longitude and 56 labs then we
have to take our shoes off and stand in
the mud
to like get our electrons balanced and
what happened all i wanted was a
microwave can i tell you i also was sent
to this doctor because i was just trying
to be healthy we're all just trying our
hardest to be healthy it says natural it
says organic and then you're told it's
not healthy doesn't mean anything it's
not organic like it's so hard to
be healthy like you have to it's a
full-time job just to read the
ingredients on things and i remember i
went to this doctor i'll call him dr
sarah is a different doctor who first of
all made me get colonics every time i
went in he was like you have to come in
twice a week and get colonics that's
called diarrhea and he would just
he would just put a tube in my butthole
and spray water up my butt and then
you'd watch what was in your intestines
like come out of a tube and you'd like
an into an ant farm yeah you just like
is that gum like i don't even know that
it like you'd watch all this stuff come
out and he would do it so often and not
only that he would name drop celebrities
he was like well so-and-so was here
yesterday and like telling me about
their shits and then
he um said that i was only allowed to
eat certain things based on what my
blood type was and i said to him
uh so what if i'm like traveling and i'm
in the airport and there's like you know
there's only pizza and fast food like
what if i just like grab a banana and he
just want a banana
you might as well put a gun in your
mouth
so these are the type of
people
that i have gone to to try to help me
be
healthy have natural products in my home
have natural cleaners natural
food natural everything this is what we
had to do before
the growth came along
grove where were you 10 years ago
when emily was calling the city for
powerlifting never tried to call a city
you're saying the ultimatum of a banana
or a gun in your mouth is not going to
work
because i think you know options yeah
after all of our experience with
charlatans we were so happy to find
grove grove is the online marketplace
that delivers healthy home beauty and
personal care products directly to you
you don't need a sarah look at this look
at this look every product is guaranteed
to be good for you your family your home
and the planet i went on it recently for
all new cleaning products look at these
cleaning products they sent they sent
all these like all natural cleaning
products you go on there like you can't
go wrong like you can't mess up because
a lot of times labels lie to you join
over two million households who choose
to shop sustainably at grove plus
shipping is fast and free on your first
order choosing products that are better
for you and the planet has never been
easier for a limited time when with our
listeners go to grove.com whitney you
will get to choose a free starter set
with your first order go to grove.com
whitney to get your exclusive offer
that's grove.com
whitney
did you feel like there came a time
where being my friend made it weird oh
yeah almost every day because you know
it was really difficult because
when you are making a show and you're in
the show and it's a multicam after the
table read you then we write it late and
then in the morning you rehearse so you
rehearse until the the the run through
then run through as we watch the whole
cast like run through the like a play of
the episode and then we get notes and
you're not back in the writing room
until like 4 00 p.m yeah there's a whole
day of us like waiting around like
complete you know what's going to happen
feeling like you couldn't move forward
without you yeah so then people
complained it was always kind of weird
they would call me the mole because they
didn't want to like say anything about
it negative about me negative about
because they know you'd snitch yeah
which i would
but it wasn't but it was difficult
because you know it was very hard
because i know how it is like when
you're not there you want people to move
forward but they can't move forward
because no one's in your head we were a
multicam show which means we had an
audience at a network that was community
and the office which was really sort of
but we were getting good ratings that
just we couldn't get through because
people just didn't
people were mad at how everywhere i was
people were mad however where you were
in la and that was what was was
frustrating as your friend because you
were like really spiraling because it
was a lot of pressure and there's a lot
of people you liked and people we know
who were like also just like jumping on
the bandwagon and being like making fun
of the billboards i was like the go-to
punch line because it was ubiquitous
right but it was still you you know so
even though people were making fun of
you and you you weren't the one who said
i have an idea let me take these tag
lines and make this yeah you know like
sex well they took my tweets and kind of
cleaned them up and made them tag lines
for the show so it was like i had some
now that i'm standing behind these jokes
but it was like half of all marriages
end in obesity or something
yeah they did half of all marriages and
in sweatpants like i didn't write that
but it was then me like like wagging my
finger to kiss i remember like it really
affected you and i felt so bad you know
because i felt like it was one of those
things where like i knew how hard we
were working on the show and how much
jinjins were eating and
and how imp and and also
there was this thing of people also i
don't like being negative about the show
because a lot of people really love it
and when i tour it like you know it
still airs in a lot of places and it
still is it's like on amazon now like
people really like are finding it again
and i don't want to take that away from
anybody because away from the me and the
ads and all that
people really
connect to it because it was it's
ultimately still just like timeless
relationship humor yeah like why are you
talking to your ex like every episode
was kind of classic that way yeah the
the marketing like we've talked about
before hurt the show you know because if
it just kind of came out and was on just
like you know like if it was like
community if it was like a sleeper hit
if it just rolled out and just was there
you know yeah and then people were like
oh the show's got the show this is funny
it's like it's like four stars he's like
talking about it being in a relationship
and there's some you know the cast was
hilarious you know yeah and uh i don't
know but but it was hard to watch you
deal with that because no one knew i
didn't know what to do because we were
there i was in it with you and it felt
like we were you know working really
hard and doing good job and also dealing
with the fact that when you have a new
show like that every week like the
president of the network would come to
the run-through and then give notes and
say actually you know what it never
happens yeah and i remember there would
be one week where it was it's gotta be
mad about you when we first started the
show was like we're gonna be we're gonna
make mad about you role reversal gender
reversal mad about you the the and this
is so wild we talked about this with rob
last week of like when when i was
criticized for the show being like
sexist that's the only thing that ever
hurt my feelings i mean there's there's
articles where people came after my body
came i mean if you were to like like
hold those up now
i mean people will lose their jobs i
mean reviews that were so wildly sexist
and like talking about like my body and
my face and saying i'm shrill and
annoying and stuff like that like like
wildly massaging the ship but
um they're the only thing that ever
bothered me was when they said it was
canned laughter because that was just
ignorance i always said to them like
come see our audience like remember we
ended up taking microphones out of the
audience yeah yeah or uh what was the
other one i can't remember go ahead well
yeah you became obsessed with that you
became obsessed with the people saying
that the the audience was we did so many
times out trying to get seats and but it
bothers me too i remember like you know
even last year when i had my show and
people that was reviews like we don't
need another like you know laugh track
blah blah i was like fuck you people
what are you doing i know but the irony
is that the people that are actually
watching it
aren't making those you know what i'm
saying the people like people that watch
big bang theory in the shows like you
know that are those are multi-game shows
people still friends is still the most
watched show so it's like the people
that i didn't understand at that time
that all that twitter feedback those
aren't people that are fans anyway
they're not comedy fans they're just
like haters but but it was also kind of
weird to me because it was a lesson of
i did kind of um now that i look back it
makes me laugh that all the people that
were so negative about me
in the beginning because i didn't know
about it for months like because we were
working so hard i mean i was going from
cbs radford with you to to uh cbs to do
two book girls and then i'd like go to
your house we would rewrite a script we
would get up at 4 in the morning i would
rehearse like i didn't see the
billboards i didn't see negative reviews
i didn't see twitter we didn't have well
i remember when they first came out
there was the nbc building a long time
ago on on alameda right yeah and they
had the whitney billboard that was the
size of the entire building and i
remember taking pictures send you and be
like this is crazy you are a building
this is insane not thinking it was
negative and then it just became this
like but i didn't see it i was like okay
like i just we were just working we were
just like making this play we were just
like having a blast and making this show
and then i remember
to because the a month in my mom had a
stroke yeah and i had to leave and real
life happened and then so i was dealing
with that and a couple family tragedies
and then i come back and i did i
remember when i was like in savannah or
something going to like a nursing home
and i was like i'm on a building like
that it was like billboards were around
like other cities and i was like that's
weird but i was crying so i couldn't
really through tears figure out what's
going on and ironically myself through
tears looked like myself on the show i
looked animated always and then i um
and then i went to some like nbc event
and i was like hey like
like you show up like you think you're
the prom queen yeah you know and you're
like making this show and we've made a
couple episodes and we're really proud
of them and they're really funny and
we've cast these amazing people we've
got this incredible writer's room i mean
like the writers we had on that show
like like
still some of my favorite people on the
planet oh yeah hilarious and so we're
having the best time every day just
dying laughing like making these um
great show with these great cats and
then i went to some nbc like upfront
party and everyone was like how you
doing
and i was like great i mean i'm a little
tired but everyone's like they're just
jealous don't listen to them and i'm
like what like people were treating me
like i had terminal cancer and i was
like i
that it was like being carried at the
end of the movie when the blood spilled
on her like i didn't know
and there was something kind of
interesting about going like oh like
now that i and of course it broke my
heart and shattered me and made me feel
embarrassed and really paranoid for a
long time in my life like oh i think
something's happening yeah i remember
that that's when i realized because then
you got like paranoid which you aren't
and you kind of started like
kind of freaking out because i was like
oh
it was like you wouldn't go to a party
you wouldn't go to like friends parties
anymore you wouldn't do that kind of
stuff and then we went to
like i made you go to the comments i was
embarrassed it was like the kind of
thing where you get the thing you've
been dreaming about forever and then you
get the carry moment where they drop the
pig's blood on you and then you're like
just embarra humility i was like
humiliated i i finally
achieved my dream and i was humiliated
yeah and i remember being like you
should just go and do stand-up remember
we went and we went to the comedy store
and you're like i'm not no no i'm too
busy i was like you just performed yes i
think like that's the one thing that
will make you feel better and you went
you were wearing like skids or some sort
of ridiculous outfit you remember this
i don't i don't know what skids are you
know skids like parachute pants okay
okay
okay i was wearing a jacket a leather
jacket
no was i wearing an olive green leather
jacket yeah but you were also wearing i
think i know what you're talking about
these like puffy like like like little
like emcee hammer pants yes it was they
were from the closet of marcel mousseau
they were like for a mime yeah yeah met
gala mime vibe yeah and then we went
there and i i remember actually we
chelsea brittany we keep talking about
where she was she was there and she was
like happy to see you and you were like
oh okay people don't hate me and then we
you did a spot and it was like funny and
you had a good time and then we left and
we were driving back and we stopped at
the corner of sunset and laurel canyon
and right there was
the billboard and it was the first time
where i was like whitney there it is
i was like that's fucking cool no matter
how many people say it's fucking make
fun of you and say it's not funny or
whatever the hell it is like who else
has that kind of moment you know like it
was so cool and i remember then we drove
back and you were psyched in that photo
and it was like you were in a definitely
an insane place driving that crazy car
around that was so
if i didn't have you i don't know what i
would have done because you were the one
that was like no this is good keep going
keep going because i just wanted to i
was just like this isn't worth it like
because then it started to not be fun
and started to feel like pressure and it
started to be like oh all the things i
want to do
because it was also like i'm too dirty
i'm too this we're not allowed to say
this or not let's say that and i just
felt like my hands were kind of tied
behind my back and i want to do really
simple episodes like i didn't want to do
like super complex stuff i just wanted
to be like you know um
my boyfriend's ex
wants to have coffee and the whole
episode is just kind of about that and
you know just about these things we like
found that there's like a bunch of
episodes that are just like simple
really fun what was your favorite
episode
people a lot of fans are asking i have i
have questions from fans my favorite i
think
i would say my favorite episode was
the one you were in where you played gee
silver yeah that was so i was cast in
whitney and you were okay
that's you weren't cast i was guessed
they were given the parts no i
auditioned
for the creator
i i i auditioned just like i did for big
bang theory and uh there were less lines
there were zero lines this is you in the
audience with me in the scene where
crystaly's character falls off the stage
giving us yes that was a funny episode
where you couldn't take him seriously
anymore or be attracted to him because
you saw him fall it's my like one of my
favorite conceits for anything based on
a joke
i think in my i don't know what special
it was but um where i was madly in love
with the guy and i saw him in new york
trip and fall on a cobblestone street
and i instantly fell out of love with
him
[Music]
i like could i could never have sex with
him again and this is about me and my
boyfriend uh what happens when you see
the person you're in love with like a
guy like trip and fall yeah and it was
like ridiculous it was like he gave like
a very long speech and then he tripped
off the stage she fell at the stage and
my instinct wasn't to go help him i just
couldn't stop laughing yes a lot can i
tell you one of my other favorite
episodes was when we got mugged and i
ran away that was really funny and also
the episode where you walked in on your
therapist played by chelsea handler
eating a full cake
that was no no that was funny that was
very funny
this was uh uh what happens when you see
your therapist in public doing something
weird yes and we landed on
i see my therapist in a public park
having a birthday party for herself
eating a full cake
and here's the thing about that okay
well also real quick i was cast as the
character guy and i quickly gave myself
a last name silver and i call myself g
silver and that's what i was and i
actually had i gave myself several lines
and then
never aired
i'm still mad about gee silver not heavy
not having the light you didn't get into
sag for that again
that was a a lot of people's favorite
like one of my favorite episodes was um
we would just get in little fights i
would you know and i want to talk about
your relationship with your wife rachel
in a second because it was a big
inspiration of the show i loved being in
that writer's room because it was just
like us
talking shit about the people we were
dating and turning it into episodes i
remember there was one
where
wait real quick funny oh it's fizz story
uh-oh this is the best okay so owen
hilarious could be in hilarious right
brilliant we are like in a writership
together and you know when you have a
big room you split up there's like an a
room b room maybe there's a just a joke
room just real quick there's an a room
in a b room and you you pretend you're
splitting it up because
like like it's just random you're like
oh you guys go in there you guys what
you're really saying is you're the
adults come over here you actually can
break the story and then this is the
kids table and we're going to give you a
fake thing to do just so you stop making
monk claire pen jokes
like you're slowing things down so we
would break into two rooms
sometimes just to get the annoying
people out of the way well i was always
in the other room in the alts room we'd
be like dan go work on alternative
reference jokes so but there was one
time season two when you like kind of
figured out like a plan we had a
schedule it was like organized you know
you you brought in a lot new writers and
you were very specific about no phones
which was a really good idea in writing
because we got distracted all this kind
of stuff which i wasn't being a dick
like no phones if your child needs to
you need to go but if you're just
sitting on your phone scrolling like
it's just my goal is to get everyone out
earlier so no phones is going to get us
there faster yeah um
no i think it's
steve jobs posters everywhere everyone
steve jobs books i really had a whole
leadership plan yeah he had a leadership
plan and one day you got really mad
because people were on their phones yeah
so you told one room owen was not in
this room i was in this room and you
said uh guys i'm getting really pissed
because i just noticed that a lot of
people are just kind of on their phones
a lot i want to focus i want to get out
of here early and you were like mad you
know because you were also doing a talk
show at the same time my face is getting
animated and i need to go to sleep yeah
you and i don't have time to cheat on
everyone you're like i can't lie enough
i can't cheat enough i'm freaking out
everyone stop using your phone remember
i would have to leave to go get
cortisone shots for my zits from all the
makeup i was wearing yeah and you give
this whole speech and people were like
fuck okay we'll use their phone and then
owen smith the door opens owen's like
six something he walks in just like
really cool and he's just like yo
whitney and you're like yeah like he's
like yo can i use your phone charger
and it was the funniest moment of the
show i remember that
and then i was like oh and he's like
what's up and i was like later i'll tell
you later
i remember i was like sitting in a
beanbag chair so i remember because my
back hurt so bad i would sit in a
beanbag chair and i couldn't even like
get up to storm out well because we gave
him a look like don't do that and he was
like what's the problem dude
and then he's like fiddling trying to
pull your charger out of the socket i
remember that oh and he was late because
his air conditioning was broken i
remember that
yeah is this photo of you drinking out
of a mug of me in a row oh
what's happening in this photo that
seems like we are
in
the i
that seems like it's very lit at night
someone gave you a picture of you dead
so there was a point towards the end of
the show where
it was it was getting you're passing
away i was passing on well look this was
also a time when you had to do a lot of
press so so
we would
basically because when you're in a show
but you're also making the show you also
then have to promote the show and
because this was a time where you'd be
writing the show promoting the show and
it'd be airing simultaneously now
creators they get to make a show edit it
finish it and then put it out
on letterman the same day we'd be
shooting and we'd be like it was madness
so we would go to new york
and people like
really like well okay
so we would be going to new york so i
like went to new york on a red eye did
like letterman and like four talk shows
and this was before you just went on hot
ones once instead of having to do
letterman leno kilbourne
wendy williams and rachel ray in like
nine other shows um you can just go on
rogan once you know
uh or just hashtag queueing on and get
famous
and so
you would come to new york with me to do
press and we would write scripts on the
plane yeah so basically what happened so
just know if you didn't like whitney
half of the scripts were written on the
plane yeah so just go this show's pretty
good for having been written
southwest so we had this idea
this is us rewriting this that's
rewriting a script it's me with two
computers at your house trying to write
two scripts at once yeah this was not a
good time i remember there was a moment
where you were typing and you just
looked at me and you're like
i can't type anymore
you just walked away and got frozen
yogurt
like i can't do this
i can't do it anymore like i ju this is
before all my fingers had been severed
off
and
oh here's us on the plane
writing two scripts at once and look i
stand by that show like i love that show
i love the experience but but this is
something i thought that i didn't get to
finish before which is that like we also
would go like yeah we only got to do 70
of what we wanted to do oh yeah so we
would you run out of time yeah we were
just running out of time that's why i
went in the plane with you because we
were behind and you had to write a
script and we just had to do it so i
just got on the plane and we got there
but then i was like hilariously like
trying to like write this episode with
you but also like following you around
and then i then i got sent with the task
of holding your
chicken
and
your diamonds that were rented so there
was some point where whitney's publicist
who was very cool was like hey do you
mind holding this and i was like sure i
was like in a car and then she's like
wait and then she forgot she's like
whitney
where's the chicken where's the diamonds
and then i went like that and that's a
picture of me holding chickens and
diamonds okay you how is it that me to
margaritas in i love that the number of
margaritas i've drank has gone down over
the podcast in my estimation no you are
remembering this wrong
i went to go do like watch what happens
live right it was between watch what
happens live in the today show or
something and you have look this is
that's it in the morning i went through
this whole timeline what does that say
in the background
that says
something what is that show seth meyers
who is this no seth
b seth myers was still like at boom
chicago
he was not he did not have his own dog
show when whitney was on
i mean josh myers it was mad tv
we were on some
show okay who was this like um bonnie
hunt
i don't know but i like that collar this
was on johnny carson okay so we go
when you get styled so a sty the stylist
thing is that you pay money to a stylist
to give you a dress
shoes and a bunch of jewelry that you
have to return at the end you don't get
to keep it it's a five thousand dollar
dress two thousand dollar shoes and they
even like eighty thousand dollars worth
of diamonds to wear for like five
different press events right right yes
and um
i have you carry them with you on the
plane in your purse at all times so you
don't lose them if you lose them you are
on the hook for the price of them right
yes so we're going somewhere we're
running around i'm so frazzled at the
time i'm like on nine phones trying to
write nine scripts and this is before
prozac and i was just like you know a
hot mess and
i'm keri bilik my uh public at the time
now big manager uh we went to like watch
what happens live and i was always
leaving stuff everywhere and all i ate
was chicken i had moved past the carrots
and barbecue sauce and moved solely just
to chicken uh this was after peanut
butter
after you were snorting powdered peanut
butter you moved on to chicken yes i
went full girl interrupted and started
just eating chicken and uh and
we were in the car and carrie was like
where's where are the diamonds and i'm
like
it's with the chicken
i had put it with the chicken because i
was like i love chicken so much that i
know i don't like diamonds that much but
i love chicken
i i will easily lose these diamonds but
i know i will not lose the chicken so
i'm gonna put them in the same bag and i
was holding the bag and but someone
threw them in the trash
oh right you had to go through like four
trash cans in central park
and i was fully already ready to take
out a second mortgage on my house i have
an email where i wrote my business
manager at the time jeff gilman i went
hey
i just lost 80 000 worth of diamonds in
new york we're gonna have to sell my i
was fully ready proactive commercial
reach out what are we doing are we
hooking epstein island he was still
alive like what i'm gonna have to pay
for these diamonds and this was like the
first year that i was making money when
i didn't unders know anything about
taxes so the first year that i made
money i owed half a million dollars i
remember you called me and you're like
hey
are you aware of taxes
like i gotta pitch something i got a big
bill
uh from uncle sam
uh and can i borrow some money even
though you weren't for me technically
and then you found them yeah i was in i
was in nike town and i got a text
and from then on uh you were like the
hero chicken and diamonds why is your
hair
i don't know it's very spiky that's a
bummer
jesus i don't have the best throwback
thursday with in terms of hair no or now
or or throw back two minutes ago oh
great now we talked about that um
so that
so that we just went through like so
many sagas together yeah we have trauma
bonded very intensely
and i kind of we were just inseparable
for those two years because we just had
to write 24 7. yes all the time and
there was one time speaking of trauma i
don't know if you if you're ready to
talk about it but there was a time um i
i call it like the biggest lie that
you've ever told me
or or or or a trick so i find out
that we are going to go to new york like
i don't know like on thursday like hey
we're going to work on friday we'll
write scripts on the plane we're gonna
do a bunch of press and we're gonna
write these episodes and i was like
great okay so i i tell my i tell my wife
i'm like hey we're gonna go do that in
new york she's like that's great and
then we also found out that we were
having our first kid so i was like oh
this is so exciting what an exciting
time we're gonna have a baby and i'm
gonna go to new york and i'm gonna come
back and it's gonna be great then we
leave that i'm like can you put a pin in
the baby like put it in the baby can you
haul the bit i don't have time for this
baby so then we get in the car we're
driving to what i assume is lax going to
jfk and she was like oh um we're just
gonna we're gonna like not like we're
gonna go like did you tell rachel we're
not going to new york i was like did i
what no where are we going
and you're like oh we're just going to
do a quick stop over in new mexico
on the way to new york and i was like
stop over in new mexico i was like how
many days like i have my wife is just
pregnant like i feel like i want to like
get home soon and you're like no we're
just gonna go like we're gonna see my
boyfriend and then um we're gonna go to
new york it's gonna be like fine but um
we're not gonna we're gonna be um he
he has a private plane so we're gonna
take a private plane and i was like
we're going on a private plane i'm gonna
die with a pregnant wife and it's going
to say whitney cummings and friends no
if i okay if i recall
both of us
both of us thought a private plane meant
like a g6 yeah i was thinking we had
heard like a g singer yeah that's we saw
seen private planes and music videos
they're very big right they're very
spacious of course so what i thought
private planes i thought rihanna drake
yes this is like a normal sized plane
but there's only a cup it's just us yeah
i was like look okay i didn't know this
plan but i'm excited to go on a private
jet to new mexico yeah let's get a
private jet like in a rap video we show
up
at the van nuys airport this private
plane i will tell you right now just so
you understand the size the private
plane was this big and we were
definitely going to die it was the john
deere it was obsessed
it was not even close to a private lane
it was like a go-cart in the sky
it was definitely an epstein fleet it
was it was an obstacle there was only
two seats it was
so scary it was like a
a small
plane that makes little local things
yeah it was like um have you ever been
in a self tan a tanning machine
yeah it was like a tanning bed no there
was just like you've seen in rap videos
right right like that there is several
seats on them yeah that's what we
followed just we thought we were going
to be like like rick ross just with like
thousand dollar bills flying everywhere
and there was like pilots and us okay
well let's talk about the pilots the
pilots and i am happy to be accused uh
i'm happy to be called a sexist but we
boarded this this um
mini mini this mini cooper mini cooper
with one wing and
with one wing and we get on and we're
like okay because a lot of times private
planes they're owned by someone else and
you lease them out and it's like a very
sketchy
business right at the time this was
before like influencers and net had net
jets and you could just get jets all the
time this is right and so we get on it
it's also the jet is like beige
yes
like today i'm saying it's not a white
point it's not white like it was like
for micah it was
it was like the dell of play it was like
a dell it was like it was a dud it was
like a hilton honors
like you know when they have the like
office area it was like a plane that
they transport kidneys you know like it
was like that kind of thing they're like
we got one it looked like an old hewlett
packer
you know when things are beige you're
like obviously flew on a fax machine
today actually it was taupe it was like
this has this wasn't made recently the
seats weren't even like in no no no no
they it's so we get in and we're like
okay this is a small plane but we i've
never flown on a private plane before so
i'm like this must be safe like i know
patsy cline died on one i know leah
didn't have a great experience i was dj
am dude it didn't go great for him i was
freaking out okay i immediately started
you know but you forget the fact that
two girls from wild on e
board the plane and i'm like oh
there's prostitutes coming with us
which is fine like we're going to the
set of a movie there's lots of producers
and foreign financers it's very common
to have random russian prostitutes on
the set of movies at the time that was a
very normal thing right now
on you but at the time that was a viable
business model and they turn and they
take a seat in front of that plane
steering wheel
they're the pilots they're the pilots
whoa
whoa i'm like look at these little
strippers dressed up as pilots ready to
go surprise these billionaires and it
wasn't even that the thing that got us
very upset is they turn to you and they
go whitney cummings no they go they go
whitney cummings we are a huge fan of
your stand up and we're like we're gonna
crash
your fans should not be flying planes
we're gonna crash
and i start drinking i start chugging
vodka dude not only that they get so the
plane takes off and by and take off is a
generous term
it sputters into the sky
and the the pilots i'm putting that in
quotes the pilots
who by the way it was also crazy because
their outfits were like set tight and
sexy they weren't like loose like
shirts that looked like they were bought
at like the store where pilots buy their
shirts they were like bikinis they were
like bb
like little bb button down like top they
were like um if you were to buy like a
sexy halloween costume of like a pilot
they were like mannequins from contempo
casual they came over and they sat in
the cockpit and we took off and it was
the most insane sound when the plane
took off halfway yeah this and i asked
them remember i was like is this does
this so is this okay and they said yeah
jets sound different i was like
the sound of the plane sounded like my
laugh
so they take off and then into the
flight they turn around and like can we
take selfies and they're both looking at
us and we're like shouldn't you be
looking that way and they're like oh no
it's all just like a computer anyway and
we're like
what i guess i'm sexist because i want
to get the i need some men in those
seats yeah we're like looking for
parachutes i'm like dan i'd rather you
fly this plane with no experience than
those two women that apparently went to
university of phoenix online aviation
school it was
so crazy and you could see my legs i was
so nervous these are videos
of course i had to start videoing it i
was i true i did thought we were gonna
cross over yeah yeah and and it was it
was really so turbulent and the plane
was so small like i don't think people
realize like this really was like a golf
cart with one little wing and we were
just like um it was just we were
like flying around bouncing so much
we're both dan and i platonic friends
that have i mean we've i've slept in
your bed right
we have we have been in hotels together
we have been on planes together there
has never been a moment i don't think
we've ever physically touched each other
we are so you are my closest friend
you've seen me probably in underwear
naked you've seen me on
we were so scared at one point that we
held hands we started holding hands we
had to we don't know what to do we're on
this plane
dan so when i'm scared i start nervously
cackling and laughing and filming
because i was like i'm at least gonna
film this
and
everyone that was mean to me will be
sorry
when this comes out and i and then i was
like i want dan's child to see him in
his last moment
dan
was so scared
i'm trying to make jokes you won't even
laugh i know i was like look my chain
wallet is by the way the best part of
this is the fact that you have a jane
wall in the background that has a skull
and crossbones on it if that's not a red
herring i don't know what it is
the best part is that if you had died
the coroner would say he is dead and all
that's left are these beats by dre
headphones and his skull chain wallet
that's what they would have handed to
your wife and my last words were it's
terbie
no your last words were gangnam style
this is the face of a man
who does not believe he's going to meet
his first child oh my god okay so dan
part of the reason i love dan so much is
because i'm sweating just thinking about
it freaking me out so
uh i'm sweating about what happened when
we landed
i'm sweating about surviving the trip
because then i had to see the guy i was
dating
but my favorite part of dan is that dan
is this
like dana's you're so ahead of your time
whatever that means i don't even know
that like you're a guy that has
absolutely no masculine qualities
first of all i'm very strong which is
what i love the most about dan is
because
uh you know nothing about sports i love
basketball now though oh oh really yes
i'm really into basketball oh yeah
that's been that's been new that's like
since 2013 i'm very into basketball yeah
no i think it's been proven that
comedians over 35 uh do great playing
basketball
as tom segura has shown everyone it's a
great idea for out-of-shape comedians to
just play basketball first of all i
don't play i watch okay and second of
all i am in shape well it was just funny
because dan we were doing an episode
about football and we were we were like
what would this character say if he was
cheering on football and dan just
pitched blitz blitz blitz yes that was
not a good thing that i said
it definitely came back to mock me until
today blitz blitz i still think that's
the thing they say and they're going to
blitz
blizz blitz damn pitching on like a man
doing something masculine was always so
ridiculous i do remember one of the
fights things when we were picking up
i remember one time we were like what's
something valuable that that the the guy
could have that he that she took that he
was pissed about like like you know like
a special jersey or a special shirt with
like an athlete's number on it and dan
just went a mont block pen
those are expensive
if you journal
what if you journal
his journal
his diary under his pillow what were you
gonna say i was gonna say i do remember
there was one late night when we were
pitching on like a a score or something
like you're like i don't know is this
girl like a it was we were pitching on
like as a girl at 10 right what do you
mean it was like it was like is this
girl a 10. oh right right like guy we
were pitching on guys saying of girls
being like bro yeah
she had 10. and then we just started
like pitching like i don't know seven
eight and then you're like
why are we pitching numbers
something happens in a writer's room
that is truly my my favorite thing that
happens when you start pitching names
and numbers and so for example like you
know you write an idea where it's like
oh okay you know dan's character is
married to uh rachel and um
their her ex comes his ex comes into the
picture and uh what's her name and
everyone's like
lisa
leslie yeah marissa
like aaron tina and that yeah jerica
and people just start pitching names and
it's like who's gonna decide that like
and then it's like tiffany and i was
like oh that's a terrible and you're
like yeah
everyone has some like traumatic
experience with a certain name so this
will last for hours so for hours writers
will just be saying
people's names and then going no that's
ridiculous olivia okay
you would never be in olivia and
everyone's just trauma comes out
remember there was that this writer rob
yulin who ran roseanne who's on the show
first season and his pitch always was
cut everything they'd be like we need
what's your name being he'd be like she
shouldn't be in the show
rob yulin i hope you're listening to
this rob yulin with your new foot i hope
you're listening to this the only person
i know who's had a foot transplant
love you rob uh uh rob was on the
original roseanne
famously came up with the not your mama
for the for the dinosaur sitcom mine for
the dinosaur sitcom not your mama that
was him a legend he somehow got him on
the show
obsessed with him one of my favorite
writers on the planet danielle
sanchez-witzel i know you're listening
she's watching often would get so mad at
him that she would build a wall between
them of like of like drinks and stuff
remember when she would get mad at him
because one time he pitched what if
what if alex's k the name was alex of
the whitney's boyfriend character what
if he fucks her raw
and she has to go to the gynecologist
but i remember he used to oh we instead
of like trying to figure things out he
would just be like it's law and cut it
and one time he cut all of zoellis or
jones lines yes because it was getting
late and everyone's like fine whatever
we'll figure it out and then we got the
table read and then betsy the shoulder
was like oh wait a minute zoe has no
lines who's going to tell her and
they're going to go whisper like hey
look you have no lines but you know what
we're going to do right and you'll have
lines again so sorry it was rob's fault
there's that back down
well rob is someone that i learned a lot
from because when you first start
writing a show or doing anything you're
like so precious about it like you know
when you and i was so codependent at the
time you knew me before i had done any
work on myself uh before you had horse
doctors
aesthetically or otherwise and i
uh was so worried about people being mad
at me and when you're running a show you
have 300 employees and you just want
them to like you and the reality is
you're their boss you're there no one's
going to like you all the time that's
just the reality you're the one
delivering the bad news we're going to
stay late we're getting you know less
episodes you know whatever
you're not going to be able to see your
kids tonight etc so i wanted the actors
you know i just wanted everyone to be
feel good all the time and i didn't know
that just being direct and being clear
and just you know allowing people to
have their feelings especially actors
they're sensitive by nature they're
always going to have feelings whatever
it's not personal but
uh
where am i going with this he told you
something oh so rob yulin was a vet he'd
been around for 30 years he knew that
none of this shit mattered at the end of
the day all that matters is making a
good show people's feelings don't matter
like you know you get caught up in that
so every time i would it'd be midnight
and i'd get bought and ray seahorn you
know who's now on better call saul um uh
who played roxanne on the show brilliant
you know we'd get really bogged down and
like making sure everybody had lines and
i you know because the next morning i
had to go into rehearsal with the actors
oh yeah as the writer and i had to when
they're like well why did my lines get
cut i'm the one that had to deal with
them oh yeah seven in the morning and
answered to it and i didn't want them to
be mad at me so we would be up you know
fixing all these scenes and yulin he
would know that a lot of the stuff we
were doing was going to get cut because
you're writing 60 page scripts that are
going to get cut down you're going to
cut 10 minutes out regardless
and he knew i didn't we had been we were
just starting you know we hadn't learned
that lesson yet so i'd be like okay so
um
well we can't just like cut her lines
here because then what she's doing he'll
be like she's reading a book yeah he'd
always put his fans he'll go it's fine
she's fine she's
recorded taking a nap this is why every
time ray seahorn enter a room she would
go sorry i'm late
every single episode she'd walk in and
go sorry i'm late and then you just not
know what happened to her for the rest
of year whenever a character is late in
any television show it means their
previous scene had been cut or their
lines had been cut
so you took them out of the scene and
then all of a sudden they come in
halfway through the scene and they're
late yes you know always always always
so you go from having this like
wonderful monologue in this big scene to
being late and then having two lines
sorry i'm late where's the wine every
episode
she had these like crazy emotional arcs
and all people knew about their
character so i was like we would spend
like five hours on a two-page scene that
rob knew would get cut and we'd be like
and then she should say this and where
is she psychologically in the scene we
need to give her a joke and be like rob
what do you think he'd be like cut it
well i do remember just kind of like
wrapping up this whole whitney thing was
they kept on changing um what the show
should be that first year which happens
you know when you're at a network show
they try to figure things out so first
relationship then they were like let's
make it like friends and you guys will
hang out at a bar no because the first
episode did so well with me in a nurse
costume flirting with chris or doing
that sexy yeah every episode let's put
whitney in a costume yeah for the first
eight episodes so we had written eight
episodes
and then they were like can she be in a
costume so we're like i guess she goes
to the job interview in a costume like
we just we had to try to remake the
episodes we had already written but like
tried to make a set piece in a costume
and then finally we got out of the
costume barrel
of like putting me in like silly big
set pieces and then something called
sweeps week used to happen or or
halloween would come around so we would
write an episode we really loved and two
days before we'd aired they'd be like
hey can you make this halloween themed
we've already written it it is the
basketball episode
i was just like
so then we just have to like be
figure out a way to make a script that
was already so anyone that judges
television
fuck you
dude because
you
like i ever we wrote all these amazing
scripts you make all these and then at
the last minute they're like hey we need
this to be easter themed we need this to
be halloween and then you have to like
change it much to your own chagrin oh
well it's like every day you start over
so it's like you work every day one in
the morning and the next day you see
what you did
and even if you like it someone could
say we have all these notes and it
changes like no matter what happens
remember the uh episode we wrote where
ray seahorn's character roxanne
she would
it was fun i don't remember what it was
but she um
she would always have like a she was
like something about gatorade like she
was drinking gatorade and vodka because
she was like hungover i think it was the
episode where she like confronted that
she was an alcoholic and she was having
these like hangovers and she would like
drink gatorade the next day and she's
like i can i just get a gatorade or
was this a whitney or this is your real
life situation okay that was this
morning
um but she would like it was something
that where she was like dealing with the
fact that she was like at the end of the
episode she was like you know i'm gonna
stop drinking for a while that was like
kind of her whole thing whatever kind of
remember this yeah it's a blur we were
drunk during this so it's hard to
remember the episode about someone that
was drunk all the time but she had
gatorade the next morning and there was
just something meaningful about the like
i'm gonna try to wake up
one day and not need gatorade every
morning because it was like associated
with her hangovers it was actually an
episode with pat like pathos and and it
was sort of heavy
and then we shoot we we i'm sorry we
rehearse it it's kind of powerful she's
an incredible actress so she's bringing
all this like you know bless ray ray ray
seahorn appreciation moment she was like
the real
hardcore actress on the show that in a
multicam you're changing things every
five minutes but yeah she's such a real
actress that she'd have like all this
behavior and she'd be like making a
banana break she's always like making
coffee holding a bag she would spend all
this time working on her behavior and
then we'd be like oh we just need to cut
that and like just say this now and
she'd be like
she would have like nine pots and pans
out but what do i do with the pasta i
know she'd be like wait a second but i
just what do i do with the painting i
was just mounting and we'd be like you
know so um the look on her face when we
would change the lines which would
totally undo all the blocking that she
had worked on was just devastating and
so we had this whole thing where the
metaphor was like about gatorade
gatorade was like the metaphor for her
hangovers and it's like if i can wake up
in the morning and have coffee instead
of gatorade that means i'm like not an
alcoholic or something two days before
the show remember they were like you
have to say power aid
yes cause gator because power aid is a
sponsor and gatorade is not
and then it just sounded so dumb so dumb
it's like saying pepsi instead of coke
where it's like look i just
i need a powerade every morning it was
just like so stupid what are you going
to le fitness
it was like so clearly like a brand plug
and we were just trying you know it's
like when you go out of your way to say
something that is so clearly like a
corporate conflict yes you know like
you'd work so hard to make something
work and then you had to change it
because so you have to be like well
that's because they're pampers diapers
like you know because that's how it was
back then i know i remember
when i did premium blend no big deal
i had a cell phone joke and i had to say
boost mobile because that was a
telephone company that's out of business
and it totally fucked up my hoops joke
i can probably do your early stand up
dan used to have dan you dan got premium
this was a show that was on that was
like a half of a half that was a half
hour special no no that was that was uh
seven minutes and then commenting
presents was the half hour oh god i got
i got it so you when i remember when you
got premium blend was the biggest deal
on comedy central like i feel like
premium blend was like
our hero's version of evening at the
improv yo for sure right yeah it was
such a big deal because i remember i
went and saw you at comedy central stage
and i sat next to your now wife uh
mother of your children rachel
and when i met you
you were like i'm in love with this girl
and she just went camping with another
guy
yes
what does that mean and i was like dude
i am the fucking i was spiraling i'm
this fingali of relationship advice like
no one is better advising people on
women's behavior than me but if your
girlfriend went camping
i will never understand this bitch she
is off the rails you're like she's
camping what does that mean i was like
dude i don't know
but like
i remember i was spiraling i was like
she's camping and you're like camping i
was like this is not him
psycho goes camping is she on her period
i remember being like if she's on her
period she's gonna get attacked by bears
i saw grizzly man you need to go find
her you should call her i remember i
called her like over and over again like
a real psycho and then she came back and
she was like hey like you know like i
like dating you but like you know i'm
coming out of a relationship and like i
don't want to go camping and then come
home and have like 25 missed calls from
you and i was like i was getting advice
from whitney i thought you're gonna get
attacked by a bear whitney's number one
relationship tactic is called 25 times
and she clearly knows what she's doing
in relationships yeah that was that
she's dating a dj
she's dating a famous musician's brother
who bit her nipples so hard that she
couldn't wear a t-shirt for five days
remember that i remember that i remember
i was living behind baja fresh and
whitney's like i just hooked up with
this guy this famous musician's brother
and he bit my nipples like what do you
think and i was like you need to find a
home
and we need to find you a therapist
because you're bleeding on sunset
what is going on with you i remember
it's not even it's not even the musician
not even a musician it was his brother
by the way the famous musician wasn't
even that fake he wasn't even that
famous it was gavin necron's brother it
was scavenger cross brother
[Laughter]
i love that song though what was that
song
i had to walk home from his hotel room
or whatever it was and i remember
from his
tents i remember um like walking with
like i couldn't even my t-shirt could
not even touch my boobs they hurt so bad
and i could not wear a shirt for three
days because he bit my nipples so hard i
i also was like is this normal and
you're like i don't know my girlfriend's
camping
like should we just do a show at mbar
why won't tbs make a pilot from super
deluxe with us
and so but rachel i remember when you
shot your premium blend i remember you
and i were really good friends and i had
never met rachel yeah and i remember
going and going like to the comedy
central stage where you were running
your premium blend i remember and you
were like oh you'll sit next to rachel i
remember like
this is going to be rough because rachel
look i mean i'm i'm really good friends
with dan and she's gonna be jealous of
me and it's gonna be awkward and it's
gonna be weird and we're just gonna work
through it i'm just gonna assure rachel
that i'm not interested in dan
romantically
i only date drug addicts
and musicians brothers
and magicians brothers magicians
brothers i'm just gonna i'm gonna have
to really put on the full core press so
she knows i'm a girls girl yeah and i
not i want nothing to do with dan
romantically and i sit down and she's
like hey how are you
no
like zero threat vibe
she's the most beautiful person i've
ever seen
and she was like it's so nice to meet
you i've heard so much about like the
coolest girl and i was like the fact
that i thought this was gonna be awkward
and weird is i was so embarrassed i
thought i was gonna have to like
like bro myself down so she wasn't
threatened by me
right couldn't have been less threatened
yeah and our friendship proceeded to
call you at two in the morning every
night
for some kind of advice she was like
yeah take it it's whitney's calling she
needs you i'd be like dan i need to come
sleep at your house i have a stalker and
i would come sleep in your bed she
didn't give a shit
no one cooler than rachel which makes me
um
i want to ask two questions number one i
would like you to tell the story of how
you proposed to rachel okay well i
proposed to rachel because i met her in
manhattan beach studios
i was on my way to audition for beauty
and the geek didn't get it and she was
um acting at the time and she auditioned
for like csi miami rachel was like
rachel was like
getting things though she was really
booking jobs and she is now a big writer
you know her and her partner they wrote
on crazy ex-girlfriend they wrote on a
bunch of stuff and now they're directing
movies and stuff yeah yeah um and she
uh was walking past me she was she was
good friends with audrey her writing
partner yeah my friend from college yeah
i'm at manhattan b studios they shoot
the oc there
she walks past me from afar i go i think
this is rachel bilson from afar
she comes starts walking towards me they
look very similar and she goes oh hey
and i was like
rachel wilson knows me
so i go she throws your her keys i go
hey what's up and she gets closer and i
realize it's not rachel bilson but it's
just this like really hot girl yeah and
i was like what's up and she was like oh
sorry i thought i knew you like i'm
friends with audrey i
i like thought i met you before this is
so embarrassing and i was like no it's
not you want to hang out want to marry
me i was like you want to hang out and
she was like i have a boyfriend i was
like all right i'll find you on
friendster and that's what i did and i
just found her on friendster and
basically just like harassed her into
eventually dating me and uh and then we
dated yeah and it sort of it was working
out and then
i was like well now we're like really in
a great place and i want to propose to
her
so i was like let me sell you down
you're my best friend and i know the
answer to this but we i do ask this why
her i know why but why her
how did you know you wanted to marry her
i think i know how to marry because
she's like just solid and smart
and
amazing and also just
you know for someone who is a little all
over the place like me like someone who
grounds you
in your relationship and sort of like i
needed a husband i need a husband
i married a husband yes you did i did
yeah and she does i mean that's what
that's what she does and we're you know
really work well together and just had
this like moment of being with her like
you know we're in our 20s and we're
having like the best time ever you know
what i love about her that is is
something to remind myself is like i
also when i see you guys together still
now and back then she thinks everything
about you that's a little like
i think it's hilarious but if i was
married to you i would kill you over
right she finds you funny and like the
quirks the idiosyncrasies the i mean
most of the time
i mean dan like
is out of commission
for parenting his children because he'll
get like nipple infections that is true
this is unrelated to gavin to gross
brother
the fact that i didn't get one is
shocking but um uh yeah but like over
like my random ailments now like
everything that's like would be annoying
about you she finds funny like she finds
you entertain like that's my thing is
like with with my current lover there's
certain things about me i'm like you
should i want you to think this is like
funny i like you it's
things that annoy you about someone like
leaving the cap off the toothpaste if
you're in love with someone you'll just
be like oh you crazy
do you know what i'm saying i mean not
after being married for 11 years okay
well when back in the day i remember yes
thinking all the things about you that i
would find disgusting and repellent she
found funny like there was a there's a
levity in your relationship yes that
that it doesn't compromise respect
yes you know that that you guys always
seem like friend like buddies yeah i
think that's really what it's about yeah
i feel like that's the best
relationships is like you're friends
first and you want to make each other
better and learn from each other
remember when i saw your ex ex naked at
equinox and i called you
panicked
i just saw your ex-girlfriend naked you
were like why are you telling me this i
was like i don't know i need to tell
someone
yeah we've had a lot of those moments i
know um and
and then i was like well i'm gonna
propose to her
so she was basically at the point of her
acting career where she was
kind of over it she was like i don't
want to react anymore i want to focus on
writing so i was like okay well i have
an idea so i'm going to propose to her
at manhattan to be studios where i first
where you met where i met and i called
her manager
and i go hey i know that she's not
auditioning for stuff anymore but could
you help me get her to manhattan to be
studios and he was like
i mean i she keeps on saying no to stuff
and i was like well i'm just gonna i'm
just gonna convince her to do it he's
like fine he's like there's there isn't
actually an audition there i'm gonna
send it
so then
she gets a call
um to audition for this movie and she
calls me and she's like i just got a
call from adam to like audition for this
movie and i was like oh well i don't
know do you want to do it you should do
it you know why not she's like i don't
know it's about this like
it's about this woman who gets raped
and it's really intense and really
really dramatic and i was like what the
fuck did he send her
so i'm now like freaking out so i'm not
finding myself trying to convince my
future wife to audition for this like
dramatic horrible intense movie and i
was like you could do it so then
basically she
she she's tries to do it she's like fuck
i'll do it so then i like race to matamu
studios i get there first i wait in the
area where we first met cause you're
gonna surprise i'm a surpriser and she
like turns the corner holding the
terrible script and i'm there on my
knees and i was like
hey and she's like what
what are you doing here and i was like
well you
you marry me and she was like you really
want to marry me and i was like yeah and
she's like does that mean i don't have
to audition for this i was like no and
she's like let's get married it's like
so amazing but wait didn't she dress
like really slutty she was not yeah she
wasn't it was it was not a very you know
network friendly role
i remember you saying something like
you're like the only bummer about it is
that she dressed really sexy for the
part and i didn't expect her to dress
that way
i know she's like wearing like a black
bikini i'm like all right geez there's
like a future one
you're like oh you would have booked
this
that's the darkest part about all this
uh we now take a break to talk to you
about article
furniture and boy do we have fun
new article delivery i'm gonna take this
upstairs
oh my god
what did we just horrible like cinder
block
[Music]
i'm from scandinavia and i'm classy and
sleek and you could put me anywhere and
i match absolutely anything and i go
anywhere and
and
absolutely no returns you cannot return
this because this is you're gonna want
this in your living room at all times
come on i'm just chair sit on me
come on over
[Music]
this is such a bad idea what a sleek
design
i'll just hold whatever you need all the
time whenever you need it
the coffee was let's light a candle on
her the coffee was gone
got a little dusty better wipe her down
with a wet one
if you ruined my horse dress that i got
off amazon i swear to god
i will never talk to you again
what was that
article
sorry about that but articles team of
honestly
engineers articles team of designers
focuses on beautifully crafted pieces as
we just showed quality materials and
durable construction inspired by a
variety of variety of modern design
aesthetics like mid-century scandinavian
industrial and bohemian as you can see
i'm
a real okay
as you can see i'm a why do you write me
so fake as you can see i'm real as you
can see i'm real as you can see by these
titties i am real no i am a real
as you can tell by this bleach blonde
hair and these giant silicone tits i
prioritize realness over anything else i
am a real article customer i don't have
to fake it i don't have to read off a
prompter i don't have to read anything
i'm going to close my eyes and just say
speak from the heart i am a real article
customer we just bought a new article
sofa and ottoman for real which is why
we had that box in the video and my
lover bought it and to answer your
question no he did not use the promo
code and it is a very sensitive subject
i'm a real and satisfied customer you i
mean i'm satisfied with article nothing
else in my life only article you can
save up to 30 percent over traditional
retail prices article is offering our
listeners 50 off your first purchase of
100 or more go to article.com whitney
and the discount will be automatically
applied at checkout that's article.com
whitney to get 50 off your first
fortress purchase
your first purchase of 100
or more
so
best fiends you know over here are good
for you we love best fiends at home we
it is a
puzzle game and earlier i was talking to
emily i was like thank god for best
fiends like with all the fun little
slugs and stuff thousands of puzzle
games because when we were kids we
didn't have best fiends
if you're watching on youtube we had
games like this
no it's not a drinking game
we would we oh our mate
our main game would be putting our hands
on top of
the other person's hands
[Music]
this is what we had to do before best
fiends
oh wait no that's my seventh thumb we
had to play some more one three four i
declared thumb one starting no this is
you're too aggressive
this is what we had to do before best
fiends
we had to play games like this what was
the other one
oh
no that was
down by the banks of the hanky panky
where the bulldogs come from thank you
thank you
i don't even i can't believe i
remembered that he said hip hop
hippity
thank god for best fiends and there are
thousands of fun puzzles to solve
there's something new every day and
adorable collectible characters download
the five-star rated puzzle game best
fiends free today on the app store
whereas those games were expensive uh
on a germ level they were very expensive
because we definitely gave each other
coven uh people still got chickenpox
find it on the app store or google play
that's friends without the r best fiends
like us
you say
mary mac
mac
mac all justin
i'm working on a bunch of different
things working on a show with um kevin
hart um who is the best the best we've
been trying to do a show about his life
we worked at sneaker store for a very
long time this has been going on for a
while forever yes but i think it's
important to bring this up because i
think a lot of like you've been working
on this since i've
since i'm nine years old i've known you
yeah it's been going on for a very long
time it's hilarious it's this awesome
show because it's gonna be scripted
scripted looking back at kevin's life
when he worked at a sneaker store um in
1999 which i know a lot about because
obviously i've been not obviously no one
knows but i've been collecting sneakers
for you know 20 years so i know a lot
about that world am i allowed to ask you
about other things what happened to the
twins movie oh you can ask me we can cut
this out if you want oh that's good i
just love when dan calls me he's like
hey i'm working on dan will get these
giant jaw it's just so funny when you're
like you've known someone from like
doing dumb stand-up shows and then all
of a sudden they're so successful and
he's like calling me and i'm like what's
up and he's like i just left arnold
schwarzenegger's house and we were
working on something and there was a
mini horse in the kitchen like you're
just like what is happening yeah why you
know we wrote that me and see basil and
hilarious we wrote twins the sequel
which was triplets a version of it for
arnold schwarzenegger eddie murphy which
would all have after the amount of ivf
i'll have to go through
and in the middle of pitching the movie
to arnold's his horse walked into the
kitchen and ate his turkey salad um
that's my brand yeah you have done very
well they did they call you the
right they called me to write a movie
about his mini horses
they were like hey straight offer
arnold schwarzenegger has too many
horses would you like to write the movie
about them i was like i'm good yes
thanks though
so we wrote it and you know how movies
go it takes a trillion years for nothing
to happen yes ridiculous so we wrote
that we waited and then it didn't happen
right but it could at some point yeah
you never know just kind of like you
know it was it was a really fun
experience to meet those guys to talk to
eddie murphy about stand up and what was
it like talking to eddie murphy well i
just kept saying the whole time wait you
went to his home i went to his home and
i said to him
movie producer i said
if i could just get him to talk about
stand-up you know like i've heard him on
interviews talking about how much he
loves talking about stand-up from 1987
and like all the stand-up comics at the
comic strip and like comic strip was the
first club i got past it in new york
like i just let's talk about it and then
we're waiting and waiting and he's
sitting there and he's just like you
know really cool and you know very like
laid back and does he have a fountain in
his lobby yes he's got giant fountain
and allie bell was like oh you know
eddie dan does stand up and he was like
comedian and then it's sort of like he
like locked eyes on me and we started
talking about stand-up and i mentioned
like lucian hold from the comic ship
start reversing all these people that he
just like feels really comfortable and
all he wants to do is talk about
comments yeah i don't talk about comedy
when she go back should he go back he's
not sure and it was just like really
awesome like he was trepidatious about
coming back and doing stand-up yeah he's
like i'm gonna come back i'm gonna come
back imagine the pressure of being eddie
murphy because i remember at the comedy
store maybe like six years ago he would
come in on the um
i want to say mo better mondays or trip
it on tuesdays or whatever those like
urban nights were i think that's what
they call it don't cancel me that's what
they called it and he would come in
in like a fur like cape and he'd like
walk
into the comedy store hallway and
comedians the most degenerate arrogant
maladapted people would just like
like we wouldn't even look at him we
were just like his presence like we'd
feel him before he even came in and he
was just like part the seas of comedians
the way like moses i don't know part of
the waters whoever that was
i was paying a ton of attention and he
would walk through and like go in and
look
and then leave
and he wouldn't go on stage and we're
all like when is eddie gonna go on stage
dude but he would come in and kind of
like scope it out and we thought about
like imagine the pressure of being eddie
murphy there's some people some
celebrities you meet who have that
energy of just like that powerful energy
energy and it only happened like twice
where i felt it where i was went to pins
bowling alley and it was randomly like
some random night i was like with i
don't know like two other people and i
started feeling like this like i'm like
who is here and it was will smith and i
was like will smith has this like crazy
celebrity vibration everybody feels it
there's something off about the energy
and everyone's like hanging out but
they're also everyone's thinking about
will smith when will smith is around
like no one can
dave grohl has that a little bit like
weirdly dave girl at pins
and that's where everyone goes everyone
goes by the way now everyone knows where
to go see celebrities i was at um there
something and dave girl was there and
there is this energy of everyone's
hanging out but they're also kind of
going dave grohl's right over there yeah
will smith is right over there kevin
hart has that and i bet eddie and eddie
murphy has that no one is really
singularly focused on what they're doing
yeah you're just like what is he going
to say next and i then i went and saw
chris rock perform his last special like
wherever tambourine yeah he was he was
performing in la kodak theater i went
and saw it and the row in front of me
was eddie murphy and i was like oh my
god so the almost like for like the
entire time of chris rock's hour i was
watching eddie murphy watching
and then we were leaving us i gotta say
something to him and he had like so many
security around him was this after you
had already met him yeah i met him so i
was like i was like i'm gonna say
something i'm like walk over i'm like
eddie eddie and he's like yeah i was
like it's dan from triplets and he's
like when i get that script and i was
like soon
it's dan from triplets why'd i say that
i carried a watermelon that's where i
carried a watermelon moment it's dan
from triplets when am i gonna get that
scratch
i mean is he gonna do stand-up again i
hope so here's what i'm afraid of i'm
afraid eddie murphy
easily i mean i i don't want to be um
histrionic or hyperbolic or anything but
like i mean truly one of the greats
let's just say one of the greats what
i'm afraid of is he's going to do a
special and then people are going to dig
up raw and they're going to go this is
problematic or like or like you know
because there's this trend now where
people want to like dig up old tweets
old specials old tv shows or whatever
and they want to kind of like
criticize them now and now that would
just break my heart yeah i think
yeah that he's a little bit untouchable
yeah i just yeah there's nothing twitter
won't destroy yeah twitter will try but
i just feel like what are you gonna you
know yeah i don't know what do you do
yeah it was these specials they're there
from a long time ago
now what so now what you made a
television show called indebted it was
excellent i was there you were there
everything in that show
was perfectly done perfectly executed
but what happened was like
the way people watch television probably
change my guess is the reason that you
don't still get to make it assuming you
want to is that television the way
people watch television change yeah no
totally and you know it was a really
great experience i mean i learned so
much doing it obviously because the
whole time you know like when i worked
on your show i worked on melanie's show
i've worked on you know a bunch of shows
for a long time and i remember being
like when i'm in charge it's going to be
different yep when i'm in charge yeah
it's going to be different yeah and then
you're in charge and you're like fuck
it's hard to do it differently you know
and you try to like you try not to like
resent everyone because no one's working
as hard as you are thinking about the
entire one cares as much as you do and
it's not even and i've been in the other
position so many times so it's not that
you don't you're not you don't care it's
just when it is your thing it's all you
think about so if people aren't thinking
about it all the time living and
breathing it you it bothers you but it's
not fair to those people that's right
you know but you're the only person
thinking about it because the reality is
when anyone is helping you with your
dream
they want their own dream yeah and
that's and that's fine that's how it
works but it's hard i mean people like
vince gilligan who made breaking bad a
lot of uh the guy that made true
detective whose name escapes me they all
do it themselves because they know
they're like but they also get different
timelines they get to spend a year
writing something and then put it out
louis c.k knew i'm just going to write
it i'm going to edit it i'm going to act
i'm going to do everything myself and he
would say to fx i need another year i
need because he knew anyone that is on
your team helping you build something
they don't want to work for you
they want to be you right right so you
have to deal with this thing where
you're like i'm trying to like build
morale i'm trying to make these people
want to
make this great but at the end of the
day they want to make their own thing so
it's like how do you galvanize people to
be passionate about something that means
so much to you when in reality they want
to do the thing that means so much to
them and that was my big wake-up call
when we were making that show on nbc
when
january came along this timeline will
mean nothing to anyone that's not in our
business but january comes along which
is the time when pilots get picked up
when a lot of writers came to me and
they went hey my pilot got picked up i'm
not going to be able to work on your
show every day can i get some days off
and i was like you have a show
i thought you were working on this show
yeah and they're like no no we're
developing other shows like we're just
doing this in the meantime until we get
to create our own shows and you're like
it was like
news to me
you know that you write on someone
else's show just in the meantime for
when you get to build your own thing
which is just
how it is but it's really hard to
get a team to be as passionate about
your baby as you are yeah no it's it's
it's it's re it's really hard especially
when it's when it's hard you know so the
other thing is it's not it's not an easy
job so it's even harder to get people to
like want to like be yay whitney
cheerleader when you're there until two
in the morning
every night but then if it's like okay
now actually i now learn the lesson that
not everybody is in is as invested in
this as i am because it's my baby yeah
but now if i rewrite your script you're
mad at me yeah so it's like if if i do
the work for you you're mad but if you
do the work for me you're mad so what do
i do
yeah it's hard you just got to keep
going and just try the only thing the
only thing you know people be happy
about is if the show succeeds that's
right and you kept keep making them and
they can be proud of it and yeah and i
do think like if our show was and even
the executives would say that you know
because obviously you know we had
awesome executives and they were not in
charge of the show getting picked up
it's like gigantic companies are in
charge of that if these episodes like
anything if we just had more episodes
yeah you know they would always say like
we've seen the show to like sit on the
hulu you know like we just need like a
bunch of people you need you need people
to just get addicted to it and fall in
love and you know it used to be like you
got a couple years to get people to fall
in love and get addicted and now it's
like you have one season
you know and then it's like you know
people give up on things so quickly now
but i don't know you tell me you're
probably deeper into the sort of tv game
than i am at the moment you know i just
did something with um taylor tomlinson
at hulu and
you know by the time that we just were
about to get it going disney bought it
and they were like oh we're disney now
can you make this a disney show and i
was like no
i don't think i know how to do that
right so it's like now with all these
like conglomerates buying up networks
you know it's like i thought that
streaming was the place that you go to
be like the artist's haven yeah it's
like okay i've done these network tv
shows where i'm not allowed to sort of
like be edgy or be
incendiary or push the envelope or
whatever it is and then like okay we go
to streaming we're you know hulu where
rami is right yeah great show brilliant
you know you can never do that on
network television they're like oh
actually disney just bought this so can
you and i was like ugh like i
i see like everyone yeah so now networks
are like now we're the edgy place to go
so it's like i feel like i'm not i'm
just always like in the last couple
years um
off the rhythm of the uh pendulum
swinging back and forth yeah i think you
just have to go with like the best idea
and take it to people yeah and just kind
of go and just f and find that person
who you like working with and sort of
yeah make it happen because i do think
it gets too confusing figuring out like
what place is this what plays that cause
like every experience is different every
show is different yeah you never know
like how things are going to actually
come out but i'll walk away like that's
the other thing is like i'm i will not
push something through and suffer
through something anymore like
you know yeah there's a couple things
that i'm just like it comes so close to
getting made and i'm like but if it's
gonna be made under these circumstances
there's no point in me doing it just go
hire someone else like you know because
i don't know how to do it this way it
was like that hbo thing broke my heart
um that was great i i will say right now
one of the best scripts you ever wrote i
think was your conversational pilot that
you wrote as suzanne summers as your mom
about you living in the apartment behind
the comedy store as like a 26 year old
broke person driving around with a
comedian and my best friend was a porn
star that lived next door to me yeah
that was a great script it was called
inner was it called intercourse with
whitney cummings
it was called intercourse i feel like i
feel like that's been like a name for
like 20 of your things
that's like everything
and so um that's just my astrological
sign
so i it was called it was that and that
was a script that
it's so interesting because whenever
people think that i'm like successful
it's so funny because i'm like can i
show you the nine pilots i wrote that
never went anywhere including the spec i
wrote for dane cook's pilot cooked for
upn that never got picked up in the
first place and i'd already written a
spec for it
it was um but this was the pilot that
michael patrick king read that got him
interested in meeting me
to write two bro girls with him so it
didn't go nowhere but after one of the
comedy central roasts the joan rivers
roast right you know
my first big roast i got a deal off of
that to do two more roasts
a special and then a scripted series and
i wrote this show that i had already
been working on so it's like when i had
been working so hard for so long you
know so were you you were always just
like writing like
you know you're running a tv show you
you created a tv show that went on nbc
for two years it's like people were like
damn levy he's so young how did he get
that like i remember when you were just
writing scripts constantly practicing
while everyone else was smoking weed and
playing video games like you were
working your ass off making stuff so by
the time you actually had the
opportunity you knew what you were doing
so i had written the script i should
find it it was um about a girl
me who was so codependent that she met a
guy that she was madly in love with
but he was
he was super toxic and a malignant
narcissist but he was in alcoholics
anonymous
and he was this a reality show
and he said
i'm in a a i'm an alcoholic i can only
date people that are in my program
so in order to get in his life i
pretended i was an alcoholic
so i would like
to go to aaa meetings and then i
couldn't get his attention so in the
show
i had heard about how alcoholics
relapsed by drinking mouthwash
so i drank a bunch of mouthwash
to try to get his attention to
quote-unquote relapse but then i
actually got addicted to mouthwash
reboot this bring this back reboot it
get jennifer aniston
and then my best friend was a porn star
that lived below me in my apartment
complex which is based on the actual
person that lived below me my apartment
complex yes who is actually an agent in
endeavor
who also was an escort it's mixed in
with this israeli arms dealer that also
lived next to me and indeed and a dj
that would take my
checks from punk'd
i remember the dj so it was like this
whatever remix and uh so it was someone
that was pretending to be an alcoholic
and then so trying to do a fake relapse
started drinking and actually was an
alcoholic and then went on the spiral of
alcoholism and trying to whatever so it
was just like this shit show and it did
not go not only did it not go
they didn't
tell me that it didn't go so i remember
jim jeffries had a pilot at the same
time at comedy central and jim was at
monster i was at montreal comedy
festival with jim and jim goes hey dude
like i have this pilot comedy central
i'm like so do i and he goes you know
they just like called me and like at the
time it was like pilots would get picked
up at a certain time yeah they go at a
certain time they get shot at a certain
time and like there was like a couple
days a year where you would know your
fate of a pilot going forward a pilot
getting canceled pilot getting picked up
there was like such a schedule now it's
like you shoot all the time and it airs
all the time but there was like a very
uh rigid schedule and jim jeffries was
like i just had comedy central spend two
days rescheduling a conference call to
tell me that my pilot didn't get picked
up they were like hey because normally
when you're rescheduling a conference
call for four days that's good news
and he goes so it's like oh jim's not
available he's got a plane so someone's
not available and they get on the phone
they go hey we're not picking up your
show and he was complaining like i can't
believe they rescheduled for two days to
tell me it wasn't getting picked up and
i'm going in my head
they haven't rescheduled they haven't
even set a call
that means they must be picking my show
up
a month later i still don't hear
anything and i'm like they're picking up
my show it's happening it's happening
they haven't they haven't set a call
like i'm gonna be
famous but i do remember two months pass
and then all that i said in my manager
i'm like hey
when am i gonna hear the good news
maybe we should call to make sure to
hear the good news so i can start
casting because i've already written a
couple episodes of this you know he
calls back goes oh i just called him
yeah they're not picking it up
they even bother to tell me yeah well i
i remember but also if you think about
it that not happening led to you going
and pitching what became whitney after
roast the character's name was dot
remember
i made you read that pilot so many yeah
we punched it up so many times and it
was dot and then it was i remember this
i remember jeff engeld who's an
executive with bill lawrence he you
pitched to him love him and he was like
well you're funny on the rose you should
just be in it and then it became whitney
i pitched the show not thinking i
thought it would be sarah chalk or ida
field or busy phillips or lizzie kaplan
or someone that gets every job because i
was always the person that would test
for tv shows and i would lizzy would get
it or i'd if you or someone else would
get it and then it was called five years
it was about a really a couple that had
been together for five years and the guy
want to get married and the girl didn't
and
then they were like why don't we just
call it whitney and have you started it
and then i was like oh so they obviously
don't want to pick it up they're not
gonna make it all right let's just fuck
around and make a silly show
cut two billboards cut to
podcast
in my
house full circle you know it took me so
long to do a podcast i now enjoy doing
it because i just kind of get to hang
out with my friends yeah and the only
time that people like us hang out at
this point is if it's monetized or
televised
when's life put that
at least instagram story it that's true
um so but what happens like when you're
in rooms as a tv creator and you're
casting do people that do podcasts even
come up
well yeah i mean i think
you know what's so cool is that you you
know you basically i mean
this is a look at this production this
is a definitely a bigger budget than
your talk show
love you mean it well that was e oh was
easy so i mean that doesn't really count
it's a network yeah that's trying to
make fun of yeah this is a bit this this
one bedroom that i turned into a podcast
is bigger than their entire opportunity
no but now this whole situation is his
own business yeah you said so i think
it's separate it's like right you could
do a podcast and also being on a tv show
but i think like there's podcasts
there's tv shows there's movies it's a
whole different music but when you go to
cast a tv show if someone is on a has a
podcast like you know the bobby lee's
and the in the andrew santino's i mean
they're on tv shows but it's like
i do feel like i felt like there was a
little bit of a stigma on if you do a
podcast that means you're like
done with hollywood you know i don't
know if that's true i feel like it's
kind of like back in the day when people
thought that if you were a host you
can't be an actor that's true you know
and i think it's kind of similar i think
now everything is so fluid if you like
drew carey hosting price is right that
means you're done acting it was almost
or dancing with the stars or hosting a
talk show or or hosting a game show that
meant you were like done now it feels
like you can kind of do everything it
seems like banks just did a game show
and i was like she's like a big movie
star and director i know i i saw that
too i know and also i feel like uh yeah
it seems like everyone is sort of very
fluid in like what they're up to and
what they're doing yeah at least it
appears to me and i feel like if you
look like bobby lee i mean you got to
put them on tv you know also i mean
bless is hard someone's got to pay for
this someone's got to see the psychiatry
bills but no but i think it's obviously
i mean
it's it's a whole different genre now
it's a whole different thing i i feel
like it's more about
you have this whole setup you're running
this whole production you're doing this
whole thing do you want to also do a tv
show like you know it feels like in a
way
some people who have podcasts they have
their own independence and it's their
own business it's their own thing yeah
so it almost becomes like back in the
day when you heard like seinfeld lost
money uh when he first shot seinfeld
because he wasn't making as much money
stand up
so i think maybe that's sort of like a
closer comparison now i mean certain
obviously it all depends like the level
that's a really smart observation i
hadn't thought of that you know for me i
get a lot like i sometimes have this
bittersweet relationship with the
podcast even though people like love it
and i really enjoy doing it because i
get to hang out with my friends and i
get to like con super interesting people
to come on and hang out with me um but a
lot of people are like i'd love to have
you in my movie i'd i was i would love
to have you my tv show and but you're
doing this and i'm like then ask me i'll
totally they think you won't say yes or
they think you're like done with
hollywood or something because it's like
this independent thing or you know so i
feel like there's a little bit of a
stigma if you have a podcast because
people assume you're like done with
hollywood or something and i'm always
like no i'm i will happily drive to
culver city to get underpaid to
say your
lines that i think are mediocre well
because i still think what it comes out
of there are certain people like you
know who we've like met throughout like
our lives especially in show business
and stand up who actually like love show
business like i feel like you're most
people i'm one of those people like i
still like walking into like a sound
stage and nothing happening
nothing better don't you know
all that stuff i really enjoy i think i
still really like that even as as heart
and soul crushing as hollywood can be at
times there's still moments that are
great so i feel like it's fun to
to do these things you know look at this
photo of me and you hold on there is a
photo this almost brought tears to my
eyes hold on let me find out there is a
photo well first of all this is a photo
of me
when i redesign the writer's room for a
better vibe
so when you get a tv show
they basically put you in these offices
that have been you know
cummed all over
there's these couches
that's not correct do you remember okay
so you're putting these sound stages and
there's these offices which have been
used by every tv show that came before
you shows that are legendary they want
emmys and then shows that were shitty
that went nowhere so you're you walk
into these office spaces that you're
like i have my own tv show and they're
like veronica's closet used to be the
here you know um
but then seinfeld used to you know use
these offices and then you know these 90
failed pilots but then also dharma and
greg you know there's like history
around three kings
three kings
fuck three kings dude three queens can
we make that show please with drag
queens
[Music]
and so
it's this shitty like like beaten down
you know stained from like coffee like
it just and i did all this research on
like what colors make people most
creative and i and i had the walls
painted you put in wood floors i put in
wood floors because it was like this
nasty dingy carpet that all these like
like blood stains and just like gross
like shit everywhere and i try to make
it this like really hospitable creative
space for people i put these like frame
steve jobs posters up it's so sad i went
to one of my storage units recently and
there were all these frames steve jobs
quotes from what i was trying to make
like a really supportive like creative
environment for the writers oh my god
what's really what's really a bummer is
in the corner that was my office and i
didn't realize at the time that having
your office in the writers and fucking
sucks
because everyone every time you walk in
the room people talk shit about you and
i like close the door i'm like what the
fuck's with the guy's pants today always
eating almonds and i'm like i'm here
there's a very thin door you can hear
people talking shit about you and so i
tried to arrange it so that it had like
i put in couches instead of chairs so
that people would be comfortable and
like you know that photo is just someone
that had so much like hope in their
heart
it like makes me so sad it makes me want
to cry to just like that person got like
so crushed
but look at this photo of me and you
walking to the stage
from the writer's room when you go to do
a run-through i had just probably been
told that i was shrill and looked tired
and had bags under my eyes and we were
just like let's go make people laugh you
know that's like what you're trying to
do yeah and then you just get
destroyed but look at you and i wearing
the dumbest the worst albums but i i
like i just this is probably gonna sound
cheesy well i'm crying but i love
i love funny people yeah i love
laughing yeah
better with great people yeah you know
better and i remember like as insane as
this experience was and insane as so
many experiences are yeah like we
laughed so much
and don't you remember we would be like
with john quaints who is very
experienced the best and you know would
always talk about joey but besides that
he would be typing and he would be there
it would be so late yeah and we would be
like hysterical laughing and he was like
his like kids at home and he's like guys
what are we doing and i was like we're
laughing we're laughing
that was it at the end of the day like
oh it breaks my heart to think about
that because when you're in a writer's
room and you have 10 people there and
everyone's been on other shows and
people have been on frasier and people
have been on shows that you admire but
you know and you're trying to write a
show that's fresh and
and ultimately like i never want to be
the boss like being the boss is the
worst you just want to be equals with
everyone you just want to laugh without
you just want to be everyone's friend
and then all of a sudden you're in a
situation where you're people's boss and
like you're telling them what to do and
you're like i just kind of want to make
everyone love me and then the irony that
you're in a situation where people
inherently see you as the enemy and the
authority figure is like the worst
feeling in the world but ultimately
the way that you decide which jokes go
in the show and don't go in the show is
like
we're laughing yeah because you don't
want to be the person that's like this
joke goes in this joke doesn't go in if
you pitch a joke that everyone laughs at
you're like that's the joke yeah that's
that's kind of american american
american american comedy whereas like
comedians we don't care whose joke it is
yeah as long as we're laughing it's
going in there's no ego about it yeah
you know and i think that being stand-up
comedians and going into writer's rooms
where there's egos and there's fear and
there's like that's my joke versus my
joke and you didn't put my joke in it's
like i don't care whose joke it is as
long as it makes everybody laugh that's
the one that goes in because like this
is going to every city in the world and
we just want to make strangers laugh
and then you have that those pure
intentions and you have that open heart
and then you go through the hollywood
system and it's like you can't say this
you can't say this and it just like it
breaks you
yeah
and on that note
but
even though it breaks you there are
moments that are like pure joy and and
it makes it all work it's gambling it's
like it's like it breaks your heart
every second
and then there's one moment where every
where you see the audience laugh and you
see someone who you know
has three jobs and three kids and like
their only respite is to laugh for 30
seconds and you're like i did that
yeah it's just it's one of these things
like the show business relationship it's
a bipolar relationship you know so you
just have to like go with it and it's
impossible you know it's really it
becomes impossible times but it's also
great times and then you're like i ate
everything and that's why like when
people you know
younger people like are upset and now
obviously things are a little bit
different when we first started but it's
like it's not like a fair it's not fair
you know it just isn't that's just not
what it is
you just have to go you know and you
just have to like work as hard as you
can be as funny as you possibly can
that's what i always liked about
stand-up and comedy
in particular because
the funniest people always like rise you
you have to be funny like if you're not
funny it doesn't matter this drives me
nuts because when there was this moment
a couple years ago when people were like
oh people only get passed to the comedy
store if they like suck someone's dick
or flirt or network or whatever it's
like dude you know nothing about comedy
i could suck every dick at the comedy
store don't do that i mean look
let's not do it that's how covid started
so that's how the variant began so let's
just but it's like you cannot
kill with even one joke by sucking a
dick 20 minutes ago like everything is
merit-based like you can get away with
nothing and that's why i love stand up
so much because it is purely a
meritocracy you can see tv shows on and
you're like that doesn't deserve to be
on oh they have that show on because
this person had a development deal with
this person and they had to air the show
to pay off the studio deal with this
person and then this person this
person's daughter was in it and that's
why they picked it up there's so much
stuff that's unfair in the tv business
in the world in general but stand up
comedy it's very rare that someone gets
a laugh they don't deserve yeah and i
remember someone said a long time ago to
me that funny people can't hide that's
right you know so like the funniest
person no matter where they are they're
going to get seen at in in some way i
don't know if that way is going to make
them like rich and famous or whatever
but people will see that people laugh
that's right and it's not necessarily
like that you know when you cross over
into like everything else in television
and film and stuff like that but you
still need to in the comedy world you
have to get that laugh and be seen to
even be in this sort of game i love that
because i always say like don't network
just work i had a manager who we both
know
that um
very complicated person but did say
something to me that changed my life and
the way that i approached the way that i
work because i always like was like oh
what's the shortcut and like who do i
need to talk to at this party to get
this thing you know we're always looking
for these shortcuts and
why don't i get on that why don't i have
that you know when you first start
you're like i want to be on new faces i
want to get that showcase i want to get
this thing and i want to get variety 10
comics to watch and i you it's funny how
you grow out of jealousy
you know like that's like the one thing
that changes and shifts you think you
deserve a certain thing based on how
hard you've worked or based on whatever
and he just said to me he said
kill ten times in a row
on stage and everyone will be talking
about you yeah
don't worry about getting on this show
or this show just kill ten times
straight not eight times straight not
six times straight if you kill ten times
in a row you'll get everything you want
and i
and i i didn't really understand it at
the time because but i killed this three
times i killed in this room and i killed
in front of these people killed ten
times in a row yeah it was just like be
great if you're just be great don't
worry about who you know and who sees
you and what just be great ten times in
a row and the reality is
i didn't deserve it i was like i killed
six out of ten times why don't i get
this thing but i killed really hard
those six times out of ten but you
failed those four times kill ten times
in a row consistently
and everyone will be talking about you
yeah and it took this long for me to
look back and go oh now when people come
up to me women will be like how come i'm
not past the comedy story and this is
sexist i'm like dude none of this is
sexism go kill 10 times in a row yeah
well it's the same thing also when
people used to say as a comedian and a
writer they'll be like you know you just
you just got to kind of work on your
point of view you don't know what your
point of view is yet you know you see
that but i have funny jokes yeah like i
play jokes like she's got to like but i
have a great cast yeah but then you
realize like it's true like you need
life experience you know you need to
actually be able to create you know not
create you need to you get a point of
view by life experience so a lot of
times you know when you're younger at
least like us when you're younger like
us and you're like early 20s and you're
just like i want everything right and
that's you're so focused that you don't
have time to breathe but actually when
you start breathing and experiencing
life like everything sort of changes in
terms of how you see things i just
thought okay if i just work harder than
anyone i'm gonna make it but i was
really young and i didn't have what
you're talking about i didn't have like
life experience because i would spend so
much time working and trying to make it
that i wasn't living my life i didn't
yet know in order for art to imitate
life you have to have life and the best
thing i could do is just be going out
and living in the world and doing shit
and getting collecting stories i mean
you were there when
we were in the writers room i remember
this so clearly when someone was like
what if um you know this is maybe like
episode 10 of season one of with the
whitney show on nbc and someone was like
what if um whitney's character goes to a
baby shower and i was like
people don't go to baby showers theresa
mulligan looked at me and went
whitney most people
like go to baby shower like people like
don't work on the weekends because i
just yeah and the funny ver other the
funnier version of that is when you
found out about blood banks
whitney found out live in person that
people donate their blood she did not
know this
we don't know why wait you're telling me
there's a bay a building
full of blood yeah for an hour she was
like so there is a building full of
blood and we're like yeah i mean not
technically i guess she's like whoa whoa
how many buildings are there and we're
like i don't know people don't eat their
blood she's like where are these blood
banks and she was like everyone early
lunch i gotta go deal with this
it blew
my mind
still blows my mind that there are
buildings that only contain people's
blood yes is no one freaked out about
that no everyone knows about these
things
remember when i um
uh so i have a
sixth bone in my foot
remember when i would be in the writer's
room and out of nowhere i'd be like oh
my fuck
my foot and they're like anyway so act
two and you guys are like what was that
i was like oh does doesn't everybody
just have like a sharp stabbing pain in
their foot every couple months and you
guys were like uh no and i was like
oh
yeah also i remember uh when you went to
thailand with your boyfriend in the
middle of making a tv show which you
know people who want to make tv shows uh
don't do that don't leave a tv show i
did write the finale in two hours on
beta blockers when i got back from
thailand and it was very good even
though i had to go to the doctor and had
sepsis even though i wrote the first
draft and begged you to look at it i
kept getting calls like uh as uh has
anyone heard from whitney hey dan
where's whitney and i was like she's not
an elephant she's truly on an elephant
right now i can't get her hashtag don't
write elephants
that's where don't ride elephants come
from i went to thailand and i rode an
elephant with a in a bad relationship
and i looked down and i saw the chains
on the elephant's foot and i was like
oh no
but you were also in a chain so it made
me yes i came back with
you know but you came back from that
trip and you were so sick that you
passed out and we called an ambulance
and i came back i was septic
i had been remember when i was on a
juice cleanse i mean you were always on
a juice i was on a juice cleanse and
nobody told me that the bacteria from
cantaloupe and strawberry in a juice
cleanse actually can make you septic and
i thought i had a uti and i was like
okay spring break 95. i've been through
this i know what to do
take a spray some bacteria in your mouth
and take a benadryl and then it was
actually from that and then from being
in thailand and my immune system was so
suppressed from fighting with my
boyfriend in a hut
and then i came back and i had to write
the finale well i wrote well i was like
the roxanna dan thing in the park i
remember writing i had taken two beta
blockers at five in the morning to try
to finish the script
sent it in and then i went to my doctor
and she's like your heart rate is really
low
um
and she gave me like a papaya supplement
and that was before i had good health
insurance and then but
yeah that wasn't that was probably
called uh what we call a rock bottom
that was a rock bottom and then you were
you were doing that talk show yeah and
then this is a great
thing
not really but you your talk show got
cancelled like what
when it did now you're telling me i'm
sorry sorry i tell you that was that was
weird because it was like oddly
consensual it was one of the only things
in hollywood i've ever done that was
consensual um because it was like
remember when they and no no hate to eat
they they built their brand on something
very specific which was like select
celebrity coverage
and chelsea lately was doing like
incredibly well and i watched chelsea
handler struggle with like having this
show on e which was their hit and not
really want to talk about celebrities
because she was starting to become
friends with celebrities
and she kind of wanted to talk about
other things but celebrity was their
bread and butter and remember i had done
those like panel shows where you're like
talking about celebrities making jokes
about celebrities and then by the time i
got a talk show on there i wanted to
have like malcolm gladwell and michael
moore and like the kind of people i have
on the podcast now and they wanted like
you know honey boo boo and and
kim kardashian and i had i want to say
the first season of guest was lizzie
kaplan jennifer goodwin will ferrell
mindy kaling kathy griffin chelsea i
think came on
and it was like the kind of people i'd
have i was trying to do a podcast when
they were trying to do a talk show with
like and i was on it with dave attell
and that was so funny i forgot about
that and we had a little panel moment
with comedians yes i forgot david tell
just made fun of julian mccall the
entire time excellent excellent what'd
he say excellent i have some guesses
um
but it was like not a match and i
remember it was the first time that
something ended in hollywood where we
were both like
i feel like this just isn't a fit i'm
trying to have like neural like
neuroscientists on and like
you know
thinkers on and you want me to have like
tabloid people on and i don't know what
to talk to them about yeah i remember
you you got the call from your your new
manager at the time and you're like uh
dogs was cancelled and then you're like
shit i gotta get my stuff in that office
you had a few things in your office from
that time remember oh god i had a couple
like and you went back to the universal
lot your your show was canceled at 11am
at 1pm at lunch you went to the
universal lot to get your stuff and they
deactivated your card and you couldn't
get in jesus
savage i was like that is brutal
brutality
that is so much worse than any of the
sexual harassment i've dealt with in
this business
yeah i forgot about that yeah i feel
like half of it was every company was
always blacked out it was all mtv
universe i mean i'm sorry nbc universal
yeah yeah
i know it's like my email didn't work
like mailer damon like jesus guys that
was fast i guess my press juicery is
gone forever because you would come to
you would come to the talk show with me
yes yeah that was weird that was a crazy
that was a crazy time really quick
before i let you go because i know it's
like midnight um look at the i pulled up
all these old setlists that i found look
at these
oh my god aids pill
virginity speed dating no
what is paddy king sky mall i feel like
that was all of your jokes
i had a lot of sky jokes and then as
soon as the sky catalog went away i was
like i have no act anymore dj i had a i
had a joke remember because i i wanted
to do a thing where we went over all the
jokes i remember of yours and all the
jokes you remembered of mine from when
we started
18 years i remember a joke that i know
jokes you can't do anymore what i have
no boobs
the only a's i got these are nice yeah
these are the only the only a's like
these are the only a's i got in high
school
and also uh these are only two a's i got
in high school yeah when i send um
when i was so embarrassing when i send
these
i sent a naked pic to my boyfriend their
day and he got arrested for child porn
and then i used to joke i used to do a
joke i when i started was a lot of like
one-liners like steven wright was one of
my heroes like and i i did a joke my
closer was always
you know i just went home for the
holidays
and
my parents told me i was adopted
it was the worst kwanzaa ever
i also remember you would say uh i just
read uh i was reading in cosmo you sound
like a comic from the 80s you're like
you're like
i read in cosmo like um 30 tips to turn
on the guy
um if you want to turn a guy it's pretty
easy no no you said you say turn on a
guy he's a guy
take off his sock
but it's it was funny though you're
making his sock take off let's take off
his hair he's a guy
take off a sock
now available on spotify oh that's so
embarrassing and also wait there's also
oh god
oh when i was younger i'm so embarrassed
no this is good uh i mean my jokes were
way worse um when i was younger when i
was younger no no yeah when i was
younger i i used to want to grow and be
a pina colada so my mom would pay
attention to me
that's good funny that's funny
that's funny i feel like it was like
yeah it was also we were and we still
are but i dare a lot of abortion jokes i
used to do an abortion joke i used to go
like you guys i love my abortion doctor
he really like
brings out the kid in me
i remember that but i do remember one of
the shows we did at mbar after the show
uh all the comics who we would bring up
they would make fun of you they would be
like they would sort of like rip on your
jokes which i didn't know at the time
that comics like you would make fun of
the comic book that went on before you
right but you you know we normally don't
make fun of the comic who's hosting the
show like over and over again and
everyone kept making fun of specifically
those like abortion jokes or they were
because i was so dirty in the beginning
because then as a woman in the beginning
i you have to i felt like i had to be so
dirty
to make comics laugh or something and
they were just like really you know
making fun of you and it was pretty
funny but it was definitely like mean
and you were you know you were new and
sensitive and i remember after the show
i went like see you and you were crying
and you were like
i can't fucking believe these people and
i was like i was like look i was seeing
them okay you know what fuck all of them
i'm fucking gonna be more successful
than them and i have a better manager
than them and you're like crying and
it's raining it's like our version of
the notebook
the comedy notebook
this is me and you what we do we were
what were we doing an opening bit what's
happening yeah we we had some sort of we
like wrote sketches yeah we wrote
sketches i don't remember what we said
this is my bang face but we were
embarrassing i don't know what we were
doing because you were real you were
already a comedian at the time yeah and
i was like all right let's do this
together whitney and look at my face
looking at you you're so bad this is me
being like this might have been a bad
idea because you invited all your
friends yeah legitimate comics and i was
just like i'm gonna make it damn it
jesus that is so funny what's this
picture oh this is great this is
actually when we got to new mexico okay
after our a private jet fiasco and we
were on set of this private jet should
be in quotes private jet you know yeah
go-kart wings and we were on set of this
movie and we were like taking pictures
and goofing around and hanging out and
later months later
i ended up stumbling upon this movie
that we like mocked when we were on set
and it was a very very intense serious
like army drama yeah and i was like oh
we were goofing
i had no idea that like we're taking
selfies and there were like legit
veterans and just like people involved
in this movie this was not a jokey set
and we were having a time no no no we
were just being silly gooses
what is what is this
that is oh you know what that is this is
me and dan at a netflix party uh i
brought dan to within about 30 seconds i
was puking in the corner
and i had the flu which was frankly coat
i mean it could have been the delta
first this was whitney's like we're
going to go to a vanity fair party
okay and we're going to stop off at
netflix first i'm like let's do it we go
it's pouring rain we have to wear
garbage bags like every experience is
like the least cool version of what you
think it will be
every time i ask dan to accompany me to
like the met gala the vanity fair party
every time it ends up being a fiasco and
i'm like i have the flu we have to leave
you want to go on a private jet it's
made out of legos you want to go to a
netflix party put this garbage bag over
your head what what's happening
aren't you successful
i'm wearing my good suit you need to
become friends with allison brie
what is this oh this was uh
this was the year what what is this 2015
2015. young comedian special it's bo
burnham angela johnson whitney cummings
tj miller and aziz anzari look at you
guys how weird is that it's so weird
y'all look good only half of us have
been canceled you decide which half
this was oh i know this this was um
this was an episode of nbc's whitney
this was the worst episode
it was
this was the worst episode because you
made a guest director yeah and it was
shot it was it was a nightmare nightmare
this was bad and you were wearing very
like very short shorts and they made you
change do you remember this you're not
in here now i don't remember any of that
um but yeah this episode was no bueno
but you did this which was based on a
real thing where we're in the writer's
room now if you're a real person that
gets a show and you tell real stories
everyone thinks you're lying
if you're a woman
it makes even worse i'll talk about how
i
was a really big like
basketball player i was very good at
basketball you play travel basketball i
went to europe i went to austria hungry
and i think budapest but it might have
been berlin and i played on this
pre-olympic team was this sex
trafficking too or just basketball liam
neeson was there he was under my bed on
a split phone and i'm weirdly good at
basketball and a lot of my relationships
end up getting weird when i say oh i
play basketball and the guy's like okay
i'm sure and we play basketball and i
end up beating them in basketball and
their ego gets bruised and it fucks up
our relationship and we never have sex
again and i tell the story where i'm
like i'm good at basketball and everyone
in the writer's room started laughing
and i was like that's exactly the
reaction that people i date have they
don't believe that i'm actually good at
basketball so we write an episode about
how my characters go to basketball and
then my boyfriend on the show is like
yeah right and then we play and i'm
better than him yes
but it was just a bad episode
but it was a great basketball you were
great at basketball it was really fun
watching the master because oh the
writers are really impressed but you're
right we ended up shooting writers are
impressed with athletic prowess yeah
that doesn't mean much and because it
was in a basketball it was a basketball
episode we couldn't have a live audience
so we were basically shooting like a
single cam version of whitney during our
third episode we had no idea what the
show was you were in short shorts and
you also had to leave like halfway
through to go to press
i can't believe you remember that i had
to leave halfway through to like go do
letterman so there was like of 30
minutes of footage on top of it being
here
the director turned in the cut
and
a lot of people know this because
everybody's an editor now the edit was a
actual cartoon basketball
the first edit i got was a basketball
swiping the scene pat you'll appreciate
this it was a basketball swiping from
one scene to another
we should do a show together that's in
my five-year-old what would it be i know
we really should well we had that idea
would it be too good it would be too
good remember we had the idea based on
the whitney thing which was bb
bbf boss best friend never right right
right word comedy about being friends
with your boss right right good boss and
uh
that's all i got yeah and about i mean
i'm sort of obsessed with it you know
mythicquest you know just having rob on
like
you know i have not seen a show about
platonic male and female best friends
because a lot of people don't think that
it's possible you know and i'm like i i
remember i had a movie idea based on
i hope she doesn't get mad at me for
talking about this but jennifer goodwin
she doesn't listen to this she doesn't
even fucking know her the apple password
but jenny
it bless her heart she had a boyfriend
who was famous and his
ex-girlfriend
was a
famous model
who once she started dating him
was around all the time
like in their life in their life in
this is a swimsuit sports illustrated
swimsuit model jennifer goodwin was
dating a actor whose
now platonic best friend was let's just
say kate upton who was like
at his house
like who would like be in a tank top or
a bikini like spill you know cupcake on
and go oh i need to go wash this and
like do laundry at his house and like be
like can i borrow one of your t-shirts
and like would wear one of his t-shirts
and she was like
this is insane and they used to date so
she was so jealous when she would call
him she the model would answer for me
like oh he can't talk right now like
he's having him you know at an audition
or whatever and she'd be like and she
was so jealous and she couldn't
wrap her head around the fact that it
was platonic and it drove her nuts
because she was constantly comparing
herself to this girl she would hang out
with this girl and the girl was like a
black belt in karate was almost like the
owen wilson and meet the fuckers
spoke five languages like worked for the
special olympics was just like
incredibly intimidating to her and she
was always measuring herself and i and i
was going to make a movie about it and i
i wrote the script the script was but no
one
bought
that there would be a platonic
relationship between a guy and this
attractive girl and i was like i have
these friendships but no one would
believe me because the people i was
pitching to were all people that
couldn't see
women as anything other than a sexual
object so they couldn't understand that
it was possible
so it's something that i've always
wanted to make but the kind of people
that green light shows and write the
checks they don't see women that way but
i feel like we might be in a place where
that's finally possible i think if it's
i think if it's a super funny pitch like
i think it's like now is the time where
it's actually possible i think we were
like i was trying to pitch that idea
before people saw women as anything but
sexual objects and just like a bunch of
holes right
[Music]
a bunch of holes just a bunch of
billboards tagline for this show it's
also a golf show they're golfers they're
golfers
oh my god so it's like i mean that's my
dream is for us to be able to make
something that'd be so funny so dan levy
yeah not to be confused with dan levy
real quick do you want to just tell
everyone the saga of your life which is
getting conflated with dan levy um sure
you want him well dan
levy from shit scream
our first episode he was the guest on
the first episode of
this podcast yes i know and spent most
time talking about how
he tries to send like notes to himself
for scripts and sends them to you by
accident instead of to himself yes he'll
send like where he's parking you know
like p3 i'll get that voice text oh
we'll just write like a bunch of like
make sure this character comes out to
his dad like he'll write like character
notes and
pieces of dialogue and try to send it to
himself and send it to you yeah it's
been going on for so long as you know
it's been going forever i remember 15
years ago when you were like oh
there's this canadian vj
named dan levy yeah i was getting i was
getting his emails then i was getting
emails from him then he was on tv in
canada and it was like you know i'd get
all these these these random emails all
the time and then when shit's creek
happened i started getting like emails
from like very like important people
being like i love you i love your family
have an amazing christmas and i would be
like uh forward to dan and be like uh
this is for you neither of us are jewish
are christian why are people wishing us
a happy kid yeah so it's it's it's lots
of that lots of lots of confusion but
that's why i think actually i should do
it on your podcast i think it's the best
place do it i think there is a lot of
confusion obviously with dan levy and
dan levy um canadian american and i feel
like i know it's weird because you know
i'm 40 but i think i'm gonna officially
change my name and as we talked about i
love sneakers i love
basketball i love athletes and i know
like lebron levy might be a weird thing
but i think today
starting today okay i am changing my
name
to michael b jordan thank you
no more confusion i am michael b jordan
from here on out
and i am whitney
houston the funniest thing happened
though one time was when i made a
reservation at the now um massage and
they emailed dan levy to confirm so he
texted me and said your massage is at
11am
[Laughter]
it's ridiculous wait was this after you
got kicked out of massage envy
yes i had to move to now
dan by the way this dan
was re asked to uh
leave massage envy because they thought
he was masturbating i was accused and i
was not and i filed a complaint and i
won
and i got free massage and massage envy
and that masseuse was fired because i
was not i had an itch it was massage
envy it's not exactly a sexy
place itched his leg during a massage
and she screamed she opened the door
okay i'm getting a massage i'm sitting
there and i was like okay
and then i just hear the door slam open
i freak out i don't know what the hell
is going on and she starts screaming
hands up stand up hands up stand up and
i get up and i'm like hands up stand up
what is this yes i am a standoff and i
do do jazz hands in my act i was like
you know me is there a shooter what are
we doing and she was like oh i thought
you were i'm sorry you thought i was
white
anyway i'm married to rachel spencer i
don't need to jerk off to you i would
not do this a massage envy next to
trader joe's are you insane my friend
joe crazy
um yeah and then the woman got so you
got a woman fired
well yeah she because then yeah she got
fired because then when i found out
why you got a woman fired no no i found
out she did it to several people oh wow
so she was flattering herself she was a
problem she was very arrogant she was a
problematic masseuse she just thought
everyone was jerking off to her yeah
we're just like all day every day i mean
have you where do you get off have you
been to missouri they barely like even
who goes to a
chain for a massage how sore are you
doing i was pretty sore well you just
talked about really quick about how the
fact you had to take a day off from work
because you had a nipple infection
was it an ingrown hair what was it yes
no this is true this is not funny though
no i it okay i
am i have sensitive skin
i do okay i have sensitive skin
things happen yeah have you had your
nipples bit off by a
degraw brother i don't want to do it
um so i
uh woke up one morning i saw there was
like a little bit of a bump and i was
like this is weird you were you were
following your nipples per usual massage
envy no i went to like pop it and it got
a little irritating you mean it was like
you thought it was a zip yeah popped it
and it didn't pop and it got like
red and warm
and then on my way to work it felt warm
and i got nervous and i went to the
dermatologist so you recommend it oh
that's right i went in there and who
gave me daily cortisone shots and they
were like
wow you have a nipple infection we got
to put you on antibiotics asap and i was
like i knew something was up everyone's
making fun of me that i have a nip my
nipple hurts my nipple hurts and
meanwhile i had a real nipple infection
had to day off had to relax put some ice
on my nipple take an advil and chill and
it healed
what was the other stupid injury you had
the other stupid injury was it like an
achilles heel thing why a hip hike
that was a real thing too
did you have like a sty
well i got attacked by spiders
and that's also true where
i got in my sleep the spiders came out
when i was sleeping they bit my neck and
then when i woke up in the morning i saw
that there was like a little red mark
like the venom so rachel had me call
like the disease control because it was
too late so i called disease control and
they said well get a pen and mark the
the venom and and see if it's tracking
so i started marking with pen marks and
when i woke up it was all the way up to
here and i freaked out went back to
dermatologist and had a little spider
bite it might have been from a black
widow but i caught it in the nick of
time
that was michael b jordan's spider story
judaism everyone
[Music]
and judaism
uh linda
linda any words for linda oh my god my
mom my mom listens to this podcast all
the time
obsessed she's obsessed i oh i make this
podcast for your mom my mom the only
reason i'm still doing it my mom my mom
loves you uh she loves how much you care
about your skin i kill with connecticut
moms yeah my mom thinks you are just so
funny you're the best and uh
yeah she's the best i mean she's you
know i feel like you know we talked
about it way earlier about how you know
i
am not necessarily a comic with like a
lot of like damage or sort of issues
like trauma and you know this podcast
has been the most traumatizing part of
your existence and i had like a real i
had a good childhood and my parents were
always like very supportive and
supportive of me
when i was younger supportive of my
comedy from the beginning i mean my bar
mitzvah theme was stand up comedy you
know it's like they've been into this
the entire time there was never that
sort of question like do you want to
think of a back-up plan are you sure you
want to do this they were just like you
you never had any emotional distress in
your life until i brought you into a
television show at nbc no until i met
you and had you with all those
relationships you're in
it's been very difficult your trauma has
all been like contagion from me yeah
it's always like are you gonna be okay
it's gonna be okay it's gonna be okay
it's gonna be okay
you have to come back i will because i
mean we can't it's 10 45. oh my god this
is your wife's gonna divorce you this is
like this is like a joanna rogan
situation here joanna rogan you're
joanna rogan
no i'm called hoe rogan oh rogan get it
right sorry um dan levy yes not levy yep
uh lion lion
his special on ciso check it out now
where can you find indebted somewhere
indebted i think people love people that
listen to this podcast love television
is there a way to find it i think in
dead it's not peacock i'm not totally
sure i believe it's on people
excellent hilarious and i think actually
the lion special when cecil collapses on
amazon don't ride elephants that's how
we end this podcast yeah anything else
um no i gotta say this is very fun dan
levy my best friend follow him on
i guess i'm only fans follow me only
fans i'm on instagram sometimes i delete
it from my phone but then i put it back
on anyways i'm on instagram and at dan
levy show
don't write elephants we love you guys
dan levy
best friend thank you i love you the
planet come on we did it we did it we
did it we're laughing
we're laughing we're cancelled
[Music]
you